So, da bin ich.
Exzellent.
Ich bin nicht mehr afklo.
Ne, ne, ich bin schon auf seit 7.40 Uhr oder so.
Ich habe heute versucht mal...
Irgendwie hört sich das Headset komisch an, oder?
Ne, ich glaube, das liegt an meinen Ohren.
Das liegt nicht am Headset.
Ja, ich war rennen gerade wieder.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das die ganzen Pros packen, so schnell zu rennen, Mann.
Ich habe es mal nur 1 km probiert unter 4 Minuten.
Und das ist weit davon entfernt, was gute Leute rennen.
Ich habe mal versucht, 1 km unter 4 Minuten zu rennen.
Ich kriege das nicht hin.
Das Schnellste, was ich schaffe, sind so 5 Minuten 10 oder sowas.
Äh, nicht unter 4 Minuten, sorry, unter 5 Minuten.
Unter 4 Minuten.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Null.
Äh, also, dass eine 4 vorne steht unter 5 Minuten.
Ich kriege das nicht gebacken, Alter.
Und wenn man sich vorstellt...
Also, ich bin ziemlich genau 5 km, die 5-Kilometer-Runde heute gerannt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ey, letzten Kilometer probierst du mal, unter 5 Minuten zu rennen.
Ich kriege das nicht hin.
Das war irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 5.11 oder 5.12 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die richtig krassen Leute das schaffen.
Die rennen ja 2 Minuten.
50 pro Kilometer.
Über 40 Kilometer, Alter.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das geht.
Das ist mir komplett unverständlich.
Ich weiß schon überhaupt nicht, wie man 1 Kilometer unter 5 Minuten rennt, Mann.
Ich meine, 1 Kilometer nur für sich genommen.
Wenn ich den einfach renne und dann aufhöre und so, dann schaffe ich das wahrscheinlich.
Aber einen Teil von nur 5 Kilometer am Ende, das kriege ich nicht hin.
Ja.
Also, das ist echt hart, ey.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll, Mann.
Heck, wait.
Oh, wir kriegen Rust-Zeug empfehlt.
Okay.
Why JavaScript Devs are switching to Rust in 2024.
Da habe ich, Chatge, da habe ich meine Zweifel, ob das so ist.
Das ist natürlich eine gute Überschrift, aber ich habe da meine Zweifel, ob da was dran ist.
Warum sollte man für, sagen wir mal, Frontend-Entwicklung ernsthaft auf Rust switchen?
Ja.
Das macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Jetzt kommen die Leute, ja, aber das geht, weil WebAssembly und Blazingly fast und hast du nicht gesehen.
Ja, ja, das mag schon sein, dass es mit WebAssembly möglich ist, im Browser was zu machen,
aber richtig gutes Frontend-Zeug geht ja auch ganz ohne JavaScript, geht es ja eh nicht.
Und die Frage ist halt, warum sollte man das in Rust machen?
Rust dauert es dreimal länger als in JavaScript.
Dafür ist es natürlich, sagen wir mal so, nach Möglichkeit.
Für die Möglichkeit, Compile-Time schon Memory-Safe, was, was es im Browser egal ist eigentlich.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Das ist, es ist einfach nur eine gute Überschrift.
Passieren wird es nicht.
Wir haben, glaube ich, noch, wir haben, glaube ich, noch zwei Stellenanzeigen offen, die wir uns gleich angucken müssen,
die noch vom letzten Stellenanzeigen-Stells-Stream übrig sind.
Genau, du brauchst irgendeine 404-Page, musst demnächst mit Rust WebAssembly gemacht.
Das wird wichtig sein, anders geht es nicht.
Aber das, das sehen wir halt, das ist halt wieder das Problem, dass, dass dafür WebAssembly eh nicht taugt.
WebAssembly taugt weder, also weder in dem, wo man HTML und CSS verwendet logischerweise,
noch primär in dem, wofür man JavaScript verwendet, nämlich um Webseiten dynamisch zu machen.
Das braucht nach wie vor immer noch ein bisschen JavaScript.
Wofür, wofür WebAssembly richtig geil ist,
ist zum Beispiel,
wenn man Libraries verwenden will, die es nur in C und C++ oder Rust oder so gibt,
zum Beispiel um Videos zu transcoden im Browser oder sowas, ja, dafür ist das richtig geil.
Oder wenn beispielsweise die Leute sagen, ey, wir wollen jetzt ein webbasiertes Photoshop machen
und dafür können wir Sachen re-usen und dafür können wir Sachen schneller machen,
weil Teile ausgegliedert sind in WebAssembly, alles gut.
Aber das, was DOM-Interaction ist, das, was die Webseite dynamisch macht,
das wird nach wie vor auch JavaScript, HTML, CSS sein.
Naja.
Auf der anderen Seite, das Ding ist halt, ich verstehe halt diese ganzen Sachen,
diese, ja, jetzt verwenden wir nur noch Rust, vorher haben wir nur JavaScript verwendet,
ich verstehe diese ganzen Diskussionen darüber nicht,
umso besser, wenn es mehrere mögliche,
Möglichkeiten gibt, dass man das verwenden kann, was am besten passt.
Weil ich meine, warum sollte ich Rust in einem Bereich verwenden, wo was anderes besser ist?
Oder warum soll ich JavaScript in einem Bereich verwenden, wo Rust besser ist?
Also, wisst ihr, also umso mehr Optionen das gibt, das ist doch eigentlich gar kein
das eine oder das andere, sondern es ist eher die Frage, wie mischt man das am besten
und nimmt sich das Beste raus für das, was man gerade braucht.
Und umso mehr Möglichkeiten das gibt, umso besser.
Also dieses Ganze überall...
Na gut, ich fanboye auch manche Sachen, aber meistens ist es total unsinnig.
Dankeschön.
Wo ist der Chat? Das ist eine gute Frage, wo ist der Chat?
Da ist der Chat, ja.
Hat einfach keiner was gesagt.
Hehehe.
Debated.
Moin Max.
Naja, scheint, scheint zu funktionieren.
Ja, also das verstehe ich nicht.
So, dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken, was auf Shithub diese Woche trennt.
Oder wir haben noch...
Wir haben noch zwei, zwei Stellen...
Ne, Moment.
Nur eine ist noch übrig vom letzten Mal, oder?
Die ich mir angucken sollte.
Was ist das?
Es ist die...
Ne.
Was bayerisches Land hat für Verfassungsschutz?
Suchen einen...
Ja, hat das was mit IT zu...
Ja, tatsächlich.
Einen Beamten der dritten Qualifikationsebene.
What?
Hehehe.
Das wirkt...
Also, wenn eine Stellenanzeige schon so krass bürokratisch wirkt...
Dann weiß man gleich, wo man landet, ey.
Mit Studium?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, steht ja da, weil die suchen.
Okay, was suchen sie denn hier?
Der Fachlauf Bahn Naturwissenschaft und Technik für den Bereich Nachrichtendienstliche Technik.
Ah, MonkaSpy.
Was wollen die denn?
Also.
Bla bla bla bla.
Wir informieren Regierung und...
Ja, okay, schön.
Was wollt ihr denn haben?
Ihre Aufgaben sind insbesondere Betrieb von Client- und Server-Systemen.
Windows!
Okay, und Linux.
Aber Windows, da krieg ich schon mal Anfälle.
Das ist das letzte, was ich machen will.
Systembetreuung, Weiterentwicklung, Kommunikation, IT-Projektbetreuung.
Okay.
Das kommt jetzt recht...
Also, mit IT-Projektbetreuung meinen die im Endeffekt, man arbeitet dort mit, ne?
Vielleicht wird ein bisschen unglücklich ausgedrückt.
Du leitest da bestimmt nix und planst da was für...
Also, weil da passt der Rest auch nicht da wirklich dazu.
Erstellen von Dokumentation und Einweisung in die Bedienung.
Ja, wenn alles gut klappt, braucht man ja auch keine Dokumentation, wir wissen ja.
Wenn alles immer funktioniert, muss man sich dokumentieren.
Mitwirkung intern, extern, Gremien.
Das bringen sie mit.
Gute Kenntnisse über IP-basierte Netzwerke.
Microsoft und Betriebssysteme Server.
Wer hat denn diese Dinger wieder geschrieben, Alter?
Das wirkt wie eine Stellenanzeige aus 2003.
Ich darf nicht immer 1995 sagen, da sahen die bestimmt noch anders aus.
Aber das wirkt wie eine Stellenanzeige aus 2003.
Wahrscheinlich ist die im Kern auch aus 2003.
Okay, Kenntnisse über Linux, Betriebssysteme, Server.
Okay, ja.
Darf ich die...
Darf ich deinen Satz
bezüglich der Dokumentation
für meine Masterarbeit zitieren?
Kommt drauf an,
was die Masterarbeit ist und was du von mir zitieren willst.
Weil du irgendeinen
aus dem Zusammenhang gerissenen Begriff
zitieren willst?
Da nicht.
Schnellere Auffassungsgabe specs-Sachverhalte,
sorgfältige
Selbstverständlichkeit
von der Bereitschaft, sich eine erweiterte
Sicherheitsprüfung mit
Sicherheitsermittlung nach dem bayerischen
na gut, die wollen wissen, dass du nicht mal
in irgendeinem Naziclub gewesen bist.
oder so oder oder irgendwelche atomkraftwerke angezündet hast oder was auch immer früher ja
das kann man durchaus nachvollziehen die deutschen staatsangehörigkeit so wie gewöhnlich auch ein
politiker ergibt irgendwie sinn führungszeugnis führungszeugnis habe ich auch gebraucht das ist
auf jeden fall mehr das ist auf jeden fall mehr als im führungszeugnis erweiterte sicherheitsprüfung
mit sicherheitsermittlung nach dem bei das ist definitiv mehr als die führungszeugnis wenn es
um führungszeugnis werden wir der führungszeugnis stehen unser angebot dieses post mit der bewertung
a 9 12 eine sicherheitszulage in höhe von derzeit monatlich aha eine interessante und weitgehend
selbstständig umfassend wollen wir mal kurz gucken was a 9 12 ist muss man bayern wahrscheinlich
danach
besoldungstabelle final what okay a 9 12 es gibt kein a 9 12 oder heißt das a 9 bis 12
das heißt a 9 bis 12 okay die seite so pepega ok komm machen wir einfach mal a 10 berechnen
blibli logatis unter jeff powern ceux wo kann man also so geil ist es jetzt nicht du warst relativ
wenig steuern bezahlen dass es das tatsächlich ganz einst aber so dober an sind und dass es
anders das ist weniger als du als einstiegsgehalt bekommen hast um anzo ritje aber ich musste mehr
steuern mit steilen Orbán das ist auch nicht perfekt zum ich wir nicht hardware abhllie mit
A crate ja aber ich ich musste mehr steuer bezahlen wahrscheinlich und wie sieht es jetzt mal mit
aber das war mehr ph Joey fieber bleiben trotzdem aber schwierig 12 ich habe es das er hat so gern meine
assumente firmen mit a 9 12 ange Crimea seitdem gangs agiert wir auf Π-ktd mit dem A 9 2 sagt dazu
auch gut der pound tor wo ich nur bekommen hatte gestern sindぁheng leopard p şeklers jedworker auf die posterech aquarium
Ich hab ja gecheckt, dass er nicht so genau...
Ja, das sieht schon besser aus.
Aber dann auch irgendwie nur so hier.
Trotzdem, so geil ist es trotzdem nicht.
Aber dadurch, dass du...
Dass die am Ende mehr übrig bleiben,
ist das gar nicht so schlecht,
wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht.
Aber ist auch nicht wirklich geil.
Ja, hab ich. Hab ich auch.
Ich hab jetzt einfach mal das in der Mitte genommen.
Wie sieht's mit A12 aus?
Oh.
Aber das ist schon mal besser.
Okay, du musst auf jeden Fall
deutlich weniger Steuern bezahlen,
als so der 0815-Loot.
Dementsprechend ist das gar nicht mal so übel.
Naja.
Aber...
Träging der Behörde.
Weiß nicht.
Ich persönlich hätte da ja keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, da kommt noch irgendwie...
Genau, irgendwie das kommt auch noch oben drauf.
Ja, du hast recht.
Ja, ich... Also...
Ganz ehrlich, wenn man natürlich da das Allerhöchste kriegt,
was du wahrscheinlich nicht...
Was man da wahrscheinlich nicht bekommt,
als 0815-Typ, der mal Physi gelernt hat vor 15 Jahren,
weil das ja immer noch Beamtenstellskram ist,
dann...
Kenn ich nicht.
Ja, also ich glaube mit der höchsten Stufe und so
ist das durchaus in Ordnung.
Aber auf irgendwelche Behörden
hätte ich ja persönlich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Dort bei der Versicherung, wo ich jetzt bin,
das ist schon
mega bürokratisch alles, ja.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie bürokratisch
das erst in irgendwelchen Behörden ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich komplett
durch, Alter.
Oh, Leute, ich muss heute, wenn ich mit dem Stream fertig bin,
muss ich Steuererklärung machen.
Also, nicht wirklich. Ich muss die Belege zusammen besuchen
und meinem Steuerberater schicken.
Für 2022. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock, Alter.
So richtig, so null Bock.
Steuerstells ist immer richtig kacke.
Gut, dazu musst du
erst mal verheiratet sein, ne?
Das für sich genommen.
Wer mir die Steuer erspart,
das ist nicht wert. Aber gut.
Wenn man es hat, ist es natürlich gut.
Also, wenn man es will
und wenn man dann auch Vorteile hat, ist es natürlich gut.
Man kann doch nur
für Geld heiraten. Das haben sich schon
viele Gedanken, sind mir da auf die Nase gefallen.
Dr. Chaos,
wie schafft er das eigentlich,
das Maximale bei A9,
was du kriegen
könntest, mit null?
Wenn du null Steuern...
Das geht überhaupt nicht. Guck mal.
Selbst wenn du null Steuern
bezahlst, kommst du,
finde ich, auf 4200
netto mit A9.
Selbst in der höchsten Stufe.
Ach, es gibt
noch Familienzuschlag und
Kinderzuschlag.
Ja, okay. Wenn das noch
dabei kommt. Klar, aber
man darf ja nicht vergessen,
jetzt mal ernst, jetzt mal kurz.
Das Ding ist,
Kinder kosten ja auch Geld, ja? Also,
das ist jetzt nicht so, als könnte man sagen,
oh ja, dann hat er halt richtig krass viel
Geld zum Ausgeben. Ich meine, da muss
er auch seine Kinder versorgen. So ganz
ohne ist das nicht. Wahrscheinlich macht er
am Ende, also, ne, ist trotzdem weniger übrig.
Genau, ne?
Das ist das, was ich meine, also.
Na gut, aber da, wie gesagt, da würde ich,
würde ich, glaube ich, eh nicht hinwollen.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken. Also, ich will eh nicht wechseln,
ne? Ich sag's ja nur nochmal.
Aber auf irgendwelche
Behörden hätte ich echt keinen Bock.
Die Katze lebt nicht mehr. Sad girl.
Seit letzter Woche,
vorletzter Woche, Freitag.
Ah.
Prege. Hm, ich hab
ein Bild gepostet auf,
auf, auf Twitter,
vom, wo ich sie,
wo ich sie vergraben hab im Garten.
Ja, dann lass uns mal kurz gucken, was auf,
auf Shithub trendet. Okay.
Wir skippen wieder alle Machine Learning
Sachen.
Machine Learning.
Ich weiß nicht,
was es ist, aber wahrscheinlich Machine Learning.
Super duper DB.
Machine Learning.
Der Name ist irgendwie leicht
cringe.
Irgendwelche Browser DevTools?
Warum, was ist das?
Remote Debugging Tool.
Ah, ist das,
wenn man Mobile Browser
debuggen will, die keine,
die keine,
äh, äh,
Developer Tools haben?
Irgendwas anderes. Doch, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
AI, AI,
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
HTML User Interface ist in Go.
Okay.
Da ist tatsächlich ernst gemeinte Frage,
warum?
Für Server-Site Rendering oder wie?
Es, es sieht,
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie React,
nur in Go.
Alles klar, okay.
Template stellt.
Oh.
Was, was ist das?
Was ist Splatham?
Was für ein Ding?
Weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
What?
Was?
Die Überschrift ist zu high IQ für mich.
Versteht das irgendjemand?
Splat Track und Map 3D
Gaul, Gaul, Gaussian
for dense RGBD
Slam.
Eh, any, any Checkers
hier, die das kapieren?
Das ist, das ist, das ist way
too high IQ für mich, allein schon die Überschrift.
Ich weiß nicht, also, auch anhand des Bildes.
Erkenne ich nicht wirklich.
Was, was bin ich sehend?
Was, was,
was sehe ich?
Was ist das?
Ich habe absolut
keine Ahnung, was ich,
was ich da sehe.
Ich habe, also, ich habe echt
keinen Plan, was es ist.
3D vom Bild
ist das. Ach,
ach so. Aber was, was ist die,
das rote Gekringel, was man hier sieht?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
High IQ Shit auf jeden Fall.
Paiwxdump,
China-Chinesen-Webseite.
Wie geht das nochmal? Übersetzen in Englisch.
Erkannte Sprache.
Englisch.
Obtain WeChat Account Information.
Ah, yes.
Wo sind die Gekomrits?
Ich habe keinen China-Chinesen
Emote. Da müssen die hier mal
herhalten.
Our information now.
Obtain base address
of WeChat
name, WeChat account, WeChat mobile
phone number, WeChat email,
WeChat key. Alles klar, easy.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
A collection of
Javascript tools
written in Rust.
Wisst ihr,
ich habe so eine, also,
ich meine, das kann jeder machen, was er will, ja.
Aber ich habe echt so ein,
eine, ein Gedanken
immer, was die Rust Community
angeht. Die Rust Community
ist wirklich ganz stark
damit beschäftigt,
Probleme zu lösen, die es nicht gibt.
Sowas wie zum Beispiel
rm, df,
ls, du
und sowas rewriten.
Und jetzt fangen sie auch an,
irgendwelche Javascript Tools,
die quasi auch so schon komplett okay
sind, zu rewriten in Rust. Hauptsache,
dass die rewritten in Rust sind.
Die haben den Hang dazu, Probleme
zu lösen, die es gar nicht gibt.
...
Nicht, dass es auch, also, ich will es ja,
es gibt auch durchaus coole Rust Projekte,
die haben wir sogar letztens im Stream 1
benutzt für WebRTC.
...
Features, AI, Laravel, AI, AI, Light Wide Streaming Frontend, also die wollten nicht YouTube schreiben,
weil wahrscheinlich sonst Google um die Ecke kommt, aber alternativer YouTube-Client und
zum Schluss nochmal eine Runde AI-ge, ach ich muss mal kurz die Heizung ein Stückchen
hochdrehen, jawoll, so, ich habe jetzt schon Hunger Leute, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was
heute zu essen gibt, ihr werdet selbstverständlich wieder nicht drauf kommen, es ist bei mir
ja auch komplett untrackbar, was es bei mir samstags zu essen gibt, so, kein Wodafone-Problem,
ja heute gibt es keinen Lachs mit Nudel.
Und gibt Spaghetti mit Tomatensoße, großer Hype, nichts dahinter, also was haben wir
denn hier auf YouTube, oder, ne stimmt, wir müssen uns ja noch eine Stellenanzeige vom
letzten Mal angucken, und zwar das hier, eSolutions, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wer das geschickt
hat, warte mal, haben wir das, ne, das haben wir noch nicht geguckt, ne, ich weiß nicht,
wer das geschickt hat, vielleicht ist derjenige jetzt auch gerade zufällig da, übrigens
dieses Feature verwirrt mich immer noch.
Seit ich, seit ich Powerpoints am Start, äh, nicht Powerpoints, Power Toys, Powerpoint
habe ich leider auch am Start, ich muss das gerade mal ausschalten, Exit, übrigens, auch
so ein unsinniges Feature, hat irgendjemand eine Idee, wie man das hier abschaltet, Moment,
der ist sogar ab, so, das hier, weiß irgendjemand, wie man diesen Mist ausschaltet, jedes Mal,
wenn ich mehrfach Shift drücke, achso.
Ist es jetzt disabled?
Ne.
Wo disable ich das denn?
Aber das hier aktiviert das, das hier aktiviert das, ah, hier, ah, jetzt ist es aus, siehste,
hat sich auch schon mal gelohnt, weil ich, ich, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wofür das
da ist, und ich, äh, glaube nicht, dass es was ist, was ich jemals brauchen werde.
Es gab übrigens wieder bei Heise, einen Artikel zu, zum Fach,
what the Fuck?
Zum Fachkräftemangel, und was ich da, ajajai, was ich da, was ich da auch schon wieder richtig,
richtig bescheuert fand, irgendwo, er sagt natürlich wie der Bitkom, wir wissen ja,
also, wir wissen ja, wie, wie, diese Sachen immer zustande kommen.
Ein Fachkräftemangel, ist, wenn Stellen unbesetzt bleiben aus welchem Grund auch immer, also,
sprich, wenn ihr jetzt,
eine Stelle ausschreibt und sagt.
Ich will...
Ich will einen, der für mich 40 Stunden in der Woche arbeitet, zumindest lohnen, der soll aber 5 Jahre plus Java-Erfahrung haben und niemand bewirbt sich auf die Stelle, dann ist das Fachkräftemangel laut Arbeitsamt und Bitkom.
Das liegt nicht an euch, dass ihr kacke Arbeitgeber seid, nein, nein, nein, das liegt daran, das ist Fachkräftemangel.
Also, ich sag mal so, ich bezweifle nicht, dass es mehr Bedarf an Fachkräften gibt, als Fachkräfte vorhanden sind.
Ich glaube auch, dass es grundsätzlich tatsächlich zu wenige Leute gibt, aber nicht in dem Verhältnis, wie das immer propagiert wird.
Weil man sieht es auch, die Unternehmen, die gescheite Arbeitsbedingungen bieten und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, die kacke sind, aber ganz groß schreiben sie an den Obstkorb.
Ähm, die eben gewisse Anreize haben, die ordentliche Gehälter bezahlen und auch ansonsten man gerne dort arbeiten möchte, die haben auch jetzt nicht die großen Probleme, die Stellen zu füllen.
Ja, ich weiß, dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, natürlich, dort ist es auch, es ist generell schwierig, Leute zu finden, aber die finden Leute.
Es ist nur bei den kleinen Läden, beziehungsweise bei denen...
...die halt nicht so attraktive Angebote machen können, so, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, das ist nicht attraktiv, aber, dass die keine finden.
Aber ich denke mir halt, hey, da musst du halt ein bisschen mit der Zeit gehen.
Vor allem, zumindest, worauf ich eigentlich, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, da steht, hier ist irgendwo was drin, irgendwas mit 40% steht da irgendwo.
Guck mal hier.
Hinzu kommen die, hier, hinzu kommen die weiteren Wünsche der Bewerber, deren Anforderungen ans mobile Arbeiten mit dem Homeoffice als beliebster...
...Seife, 40% der Befragten nicht zu erfüllen.
Ja, Leute, ich gebe euch mal einen Tipp.
Wenn ihr qualifizierte Leute haben wollt, dann solltet ihr vielleicht euch ein bisschen daran auch orientieren, was die Leute wollen.
Ihr könnt nicht einfach nur sagen, wir finden keine Leute, ja, aber wir wollen auch nichts ändern dran.
Wie die Leute wollen, was haben, was ihnen wichtig ist, nee, nee, das ist nicht zu leisten von uns.
Aber die Leute kommen nicht zu...
...Zu uns, Mann.
Ich verstehe die Logik dahinter nicht.
Wie soll...
Ich meine, mal ganz davon aussehen, wir reden doch jetzt hier nicht von irgendwelchen Vor-Ort-Versicherungsverkäufern oder sowas.
Wir reden von irgendwelchen IT-Leuten, die sich um Cloud-Sachen kümmern, um Windows-Sachen kümmern, um Linux-Sachen kümmern, um Server-Sachen.
Das kannst du zu einem Großteil remote machen, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Wenn das nicht geht...
Also, neben den wirklich ganz spezifischen Sachen, wo es wirklich nicht geht, so nach dem Motto, jemand, der ins Rechenzentrum fahren muss, ab und zu, aber der kann wenigstens das zu 50, 60 Prozent machen.
Ja, jemand, der vor Ort irgendwelche Sachen anschließen muss.
Aber, wenn du das willst als Arbeitgeber, dann kannst du das auch machen.
Es ist ja nicht alles oder nichts, sondern man muss halt gucken, dass man es so gut wie möglich eben hinbekommt.
Und wenn jemand vielleicht zweimal die Woche ins Rechenzentrum vor Ort muss, weil es eben zu seinen Aufgaben gehört, ja, dann muss er das machen.
Aber dann kann man ihm wenigstens die restlichen Tage ermöglichen, das remote zu machen und nicht zu sagen, ja, dann komm mal gefälligst in die Arbeit oder was.
Wisst ihr, ich finde diese... Das ist so paradox.
Auf der einen Seite beschweren die sich, dass sie keine Leute finden, aber da sind 40 Prozent, wir wollen nicht das machen, was wir machen müssten, um Leute zu finden.
Also, das verstehe ich nicht.
Zumindest, der Rest ist halt altbekanntes.
Die Bitkom meckert wieder.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, Bitkom ist ja quasi so ein, so ein, wie nennt man das?
Weiß gar nicht, was sagen die selbst zu sich?
Letztendlich ist das so eine Art Lobby, Arbeitgeber-Lobby-Vertretung.
Branchenverband der Deutschen Informations- und Telekommunikationsbranche, ja, genau.
Arbeitgebernah, ja, das trifft ganz gut.
Also, das ist...
Die sind seit Jahren übrigens schon.
Ich hab, ich hab, glaube ich, ich hab, glaube ich, vor...
Ich hab vor über zehn Jahren schon ein Video zugemacht.
Nein, nein, das ist nicht...
Das ist wahrscheinlich so alt, das findet man gar nicht.
Ich hab vor über zehn Jahren schon ein Video gemacht zu Fachkräftemangel.
Und da haben die schon genau das gleiche erzählt.
Elo Tricks Relive, ja.
Max FPS Fachkräftemangel.
Ich würde sagen, da passt natürlich Elo Tricks Relive enorm gut rein.
In diese Suchergebnisse, Google.
Learn the truth, Java.
Okay, man...
Alter.
Man findet...
Man findet das Video nicht.
Die YouTube-Suche ist so krass pepega.
Ich hab da vor über zehn Jahren schon mal ein Video zugemacht.
Da haben die mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche drin erzählt, ja.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schöne ist?
Für uns.
Zumindest die Leute, die hier in der IT.
In der IT-Branche tätig sind.
Und ich weiß, da sind wir einige im Stream.
Was ja auch vom Stream-Content her meistens irgendwie zu erwarten ist.
Für uns ist das letztendlich eine gute Sache.
Wir können es uns nicht nur aussuchen, oftmals.
Wir können auch noch teilweise unverschämte Forderungen stellen, mit denen man durchkommt.
Aber, Pech gehabt.
Ich denke mir, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, warum sollte man es nicht machen?
Und die Forderungen werden bald nicht mehr unverschämt sein.
Unverschämt sind die nur, wenn es nur ein paar sagen.
Wenn es die Mehrheit der Leute sagt, dann nicht mehr.
Dann sind sie halt einfach normal.
Also, guck mal.
77% befürchten, dass die Situation sich verschärfen wird, während bloß 3% von einer Besserung ausgehen.
Ich geh auch nicht von einer Besserung aus.
Weil du eigentlich wieder YouTube stellst, ja.
Ich muss erst mal meine Steuererklärung jetzt machen.
Eigentlich wollte ich letzte Woche sogar schon was aufnehmen.
Guck mal.
Ich mein, man hätte...
Man hätte das ja...
Ich sag's ja mal nur, ne.
Man hätte es ja 2009 schon kommen sehen können.
Dass das immer problematischer wird.
Man hätte es ja durchaus kommen sehen können.
Und eventuell versuchen, zu gegenzusteuern.
Aber das...
So vorausschauend ist ja da eh nicht unser Ding, was das angeht.
Übrigens, was auch witzig ist...
Steht das hier drin damit?
Experte?
Ne.
Es gibt...
Es gibt eine Definition von irgendeinem Amt, ab wann man als Fachkraft-Experte...
Warte mal.
Fachkraft-Experte-Spezialist gilt.
Hier.
Ja.
Fachkraft...
Hä?
Hier.
Definition.
Fachkräfte haben eine mindestens zweijährige Berufsausbildung absolviert.
Spezialisten haben eine Meister- oder Technikausbildung absolviert.
Und...
Ne.
Mit Experten...
Das ist ja auch wieder...
Das ist...
Das ist von irgendeinem...
Das ist von irgendeinem Amt.
Aber...
Das Ding ist halt...
Ausbildung...
Vierjährige Hochschulausbildung...
Das Problem ist, das deckt sich überhaupt nicht mit dem, wie das in der Wirtschaft gesehen
wird.
Du bist nicht Experte, nur weil du was studiert hast.
Oder du bist nicht automatisch irgendwie Spezialist, weil du eine Ausbildung gemacht hast.
Du bist Experte in einem Bereich.
Wenn du dich damit vielleicht mal irgendwie fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre beschäftigt hast
und...
Sag mal so...
Ist es egal, ob du dich fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre...
Ob du was...
Ob du das...
Ob du das auch kannst in dem Bereich.
Ob du jetzt einfach noch drei, vier Jahre studiert hast in Informatik, juckt da kein
Mensch.
Ist von der IHK...
Ja, es ist...
Es ist total weird, dass das...
Dass das so bezeichnet wird.
Die haben hauptsächlich einen Mangel...
Also natürlich...
Es gibt einen Mangel an Leuten, die das machen.
Komischerweise.
Ja.
Das liegt daran, dass es viele Betriebe gibt, die keinen Bock haben, auszubilden.
Es gibt aber vor allem einen riesen Mangel in erfahrenen Leuten.
Wo sich aber dann wieder...
Wie sagt man so schön?
Der Hund in den Schwanz beißt?
Oder ist das nicht so ein olles Sprichwort?
Wenn die nämlich keinen Bock haben, auszubilden, dass die Leute, die heute neu sind...
Oder denen eine Chance zu geben, ja?
Die Leute, die heute neu sind, vielleicht in fünf Jahren dann wirklich Experte in irgendwas
sind, dann werden es halt immer weniger Experten.
Wundert es wirklich, dass die IHK-Bezeichnungen weird sind?
Nee.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Qualifikationen treffen auf Gehaltsvorstellungen.
26% der Firmen erhalten schlicht keine Bewerbung auf die ausgeschriebenen Stellen.
Naja, bei manchen Stellenanzeigen, die wir uns hier im Stream schon angeguckt haben...
Und das sind nicht zu wenige gewesen...
Kann ich das durchaus verstehen, dass sich da jemand drauf bewirbt.
So nach dem Motto...
Suche Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung.
Bezahle 35k.
In München.
Ja wie, du willst neben deiner Wohnung dir auch noch was zu essen kaufen können?
Nee.
So viel Luxus gibt es nicht.
Also bei vielen Stellenanzeigen muss man sich echt nicht wundern, dass sich da keiner drauf bewirbt.
Das Ding ist halt...
Die Leute haben halt heute die Auswahl.
Und wenn du da so eine richtige, miese Stellenanzeige hast...
Dann ist das der erste Eindruck.
Der erste Eindruck, den ein potenzieller Bewerber von dir hat.
Das müssen die Unternehmen im Endeffekt halt auch mal lernen.
Dass es in beide Richtungen geht.
Gerade in der IT in der heutigen Zeit.
Ich hab irgendwas...
Was ist das denn?
Irgendwas im Hals, man.
Gachibast.
Zumindest...
Es geht ja beidseitig.
Gerade in der IT und in der heutigen Zeit...
So eine Stellenanzeige...
Ist der erste Eindruck.
Ist der erste Eindruck, den wir quasi als Bewerber bekommen von dem jeweiligen Laden.
Und sollte man sich dort bewerben, ist das der erste Eindruck, den die von uns bekommen.
Das heißt, man muss in beiden Fällen gucken, dass das einen guten Eindruck macht.
Und viele Stellenanzeigen, wir gucken uns hier regelmäßig im Stream was an, machen keinen guten Eindruck.
Oder aber maximal ein, naja, ist halt so wie alles andere auch Eindruck.
Und damit...
Stichste halt nicht wirklich raus, dass jemand sagt, oh ja, da würde ich gerne hin.
Oder...
Die Leute müssen ja noch nicht mal sagen, oh, da würde ich gerne hin.
Es reicht ja schon, wenn die Stellenanzeige so gut ist, dass die Leute sagen, aha...
Ich google mal nach dem Laden.
Das ist ja schon...
Das ist quasi...
Der erste Step von...
Also im Bewerbungsprozess wäre das...
Die lesen deine Bewerbung und schmeißen sie nicht gleich weg.
Und legen sie erst mal auf einen Stapel mit, gucken wir uns später an.
So.
Das ist das, was die auch schaffen müssen.
Und zwar muss die Stellenanzeige...
Weil ich meine, du kennst die meisten Unternehmen ja erst mal gar nicht.
Und du siehst eine Stellenanzeige und denkst dir, oh boah, ist die kacke.
Oder boah, ist die langweilig.
Oder...
So nur noch 15.
Und guckst weiter.
Wenn du eine hast, wo du denkst, ey, das ist lustig geschrieben.
Oder...
Das klingt ja eigentlich ganz spannend.
Oder die ist so doof, da muss ich mal nach.
Gibt ja auch welche, die machen es auf die Taktik.
Wenn du dann...
Wenn du dann schon mal ein zweites Tab aufmachst.
Und das Unternehmen in Google suchst.
Oder bei denen auf der Homepage ein bisschen rumguckst.
Da haben sie schon mal gewonnen.
Dann bist du schon mal dran.
Und das schaffen ja viele Stellenanzeigen gar nicht.
Die meisten Stellenanzeigen sind halt auch so super 0815 langweilig.
Wir sind XYZ GmbH sowieso.
Und...
Wir haben ein junges, dynamisches Team mit flachen Hierarchien.
Als einer der Marktführer im Bereich von XY sind wir stets bestrebt, unseren Kunden höchste Qualität...
So, ab dem Zeitpunkt schläfst du schon.
Und irgendwie fallen gefühlt mindestens 50% der Stellenanzeigen mit so einem Gelaber an.
Da denkst du halt immer, Alter, ist das langweilig.
Ey, wir haben übrigens noch zwei Stellenanzeigen auf, die wir uns angucken müssen.
Vom letzten Mal haben wir mal gleich...
Es hat nichts, was ich jetzt erzähle, nichts mit denen, die da offen sind, zu tun.
Die hab ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Zentraler Knackpunkt ist jedoch das Gehalt.
Nein, wirklich!
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Die Leute wollen Geld verdienen, wenn sie arbeiten gehen.
Fuck, man!
Hättet ihr das erwartet?
Dass das Wichtigste beim Arbeiten gehen das Gehalt ist?
Also ich hätte gedacht, so Obstkörbe vielleicht, so ein Tischkicker oder eine Playstation
oder regelmäßige Firmen-Events.
Aber, aber du hast ja auch nicht die Zeit, um das Geld zu verdienen.
Du hast ja auch nicht die Zeit, um das Geld zu verdienen.
Aber doch nicht das Gehalt, man!
Wer will denn auch schon Geld verdienen?
Das richtige High Performer-Cry-Z-Mindset ist, wenn die Vision stimmt, ist das Gehalt
egal.
Du gehst wegen der familiären Atmosphäre.
Ja, ich auch, ich auch.
Das ist hauptsächlicher Grund.
Ja.
Ja, außerdem können die froh sein.
Außerdem können die froh sein, dass sie dort arbeiten dürfen.
Wo sehen sie sich in fünf Jahren?
Das wirkt schlimm heute.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Zentrale Erkrankung.
Hier seien die Vorstellungen der Bewerber falsch.
Okay, Leute, Leute, merke, merke.
Ihr seid Arbeitgeber.
Die Leute wollen nicht zu euch.
Ein hauptsächlicher Grund, dass sie nicht zu euch gehen, sondern woanders hin, ist das Gehalt.
Aber nicht, ihr liegt falsch, sondern die Vorstellungen der Bewerber sind falsch.
Das Dumme ist nur, dass sie sich damit quasi selbst debunked haben, weil die Vorstellung der Bewerber scheint ja nicht so falsch zu sein, wenn andere das bezahlen und die einfach woanders hingehen.
Weil würde das nicht so sein, würden die Bewerber ihnen ja mit dem Gehalt entgegenkommen.
Weil wenn du die Chance hast, äh, also wenn du nirgendswo die Chance hättest, das Gehalt zu bekommen, dann würden die Leute Zähne knirschen und irgendwann sagen, ja, okay, ich mach's auch für weniger.
Aber es scheint ja nicht so zu sein.
Also, die haben sich quasi mit dieser Aussage komplett selbst debunked schon wieder.
Das wäre überhaupt nicht der Fall, wenn es so wäre.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Was ich gar nicht bezweifeln möchte, ist, ich will das auch zwar nicht zu einseitig aus Bewerbersicht sehen.
Was ich überhaupt nicht bezweifle, ist, dass die Leute, die da sind, die da sind, die da sind, die da sind, die da sind.
Was ich gar nicht bezweifeln möchte, ist, dass tatsächlich gerade etwas kleinere Läden wirklich Probleme haben, diese Gehaltsvorstellungen bezahlen zu können.
Das verstehe ich.
Das verstehe ich, dass die Probleme haben.
Sagen wir mal so die 0815-IT-Klitsche, die irgendwie so drei Racks von irgendwelchen Handwerksbetrieben betreut und ein bisschen Webpräsenz-Zeug macht für umliegende Blumenläden und sonst was.
Ja, also irgendwelche kleinen...
Die können dir nicht 100k plus bezahlen für einen Admin.
Das kriegen die einfach nicht gebacken.
Also ich würde aber trotzdem da nicht sagen, dass die Vorstellungen der Bewerber falsch sind.
Die Vorstellung ist schon richtig, weil woanders kriegen sie es ja.
Zumal, das ist halt das Ding, auf der einen Seite wollen die Läden kein Homeoffice anbieten, aber sie konkurrieren halt direkt mit Unternehmen,
die Homeoffice anbieten plus mehr Geld bezahlen.
Und da ist es halt das Ding, warum?
Sie konkurrieren halt quasi deutschlandweit, wenn nicht international um die Leute.
Und dann kann man nicht sagen, dass die Vorstellung der Bewerber falsch ist.
Die Vorstellung der Bewerber ist genau richtig.
Die Möglichkeiten der Läden sind halt begrenzt.
Ich meine, wir wissen doch, was denen am liebsten wäre.
Am liebsten wäre denen...
... 150.000 Stellen, die offen sind, sondern es gäbe 150.000 zu viele Bewerber.
Oder am besten 2 Millionen zu viele Bewerber.
Dass man sich dann den krassesten vom krassesten raussuchen kann für 45k im Jahr.
Das wäre denen natürlich am liebsten.
Aber das ist halt nicht so.
Damit müssen sie klarkommen.
Das war mal so, aber das ist nicht so.
Und das wird wahrscheinlich auch absehbare Zeit, wenn überhaupt, jemals wieder so werden.
Nicht werden.
Warum?
Warum genau?
Jo, jo, jo, jo, was ist das?
Warum hast du das gepostet?
Inwieweit steht das hier?
Zusammenhang.
My Workday Jobs.
Is one of the global market leaders in the development production of...
Okay, das ist schon so typisch bla bla bla Intro, so wie alles.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei.
Übrigens, man stellt sich ja so vor, ach so viel ist das gar nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Es sind tatsächlich, also ich sehe das praktisch bei mir.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit gehen mindestens zwei Leute in den nächsten zwei Jahren, also nur aus meinem Team, nur aus meinem Team, gehen mindestens zwei Leute in Rente in den nächsten zwei Jahren.
Die sind jetzt schon in Altersteilzeit.
Ein dritter auch in dieser Zeit ungefähr, so, der ist aber noch nicht in Altersteilzeit.
Und von meinem Kollegen im Team gehen auch zwei in Rente.
Also das ist wirklich hart.
Das werden auf einen Schlag viel weniger.
Ja, geil.
Benefits.
Sicherer Arbeitsplatz und gutes Betriebsklima.
Ich würde mal ehrlich gesagt sagen, also ich bin ja jemand, für mich ist sicherer Arbeitsplatz an sich noch gar nicht mal so das schlagende Argument in der heutigen Zeit.
Weil egal, als ITler oder als Techniker, der ein bisschen Plan hat, findest du eh immer was.
Und gutes Betriebsklima sollte für mich Voraussetzung sein, dass ich überhaupt in Erwägung ziehe, da anzufangen.
Bestes Benefit ist pünktliches Gehalt, ja.
Oder letztens, wir haben doch letztens irgendwo geschrieben.
Irgendwo hat doch jemand geschrieben in der Stellenanzeige, äh, ähm, wie haben die das geschrieben?
Zwölf Monatsgehälter oder sowas, hat doch letztens irgendjemand reingeschrieben.
Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, wie?
Das ist ein Benefit, dass du monatlich Geld bezahlt bekommst?
Wo sind wir denn, ne?
Also, da kann man sich aber echt glücklich schätzen, dass man überhaupt bezahlt wird für seine Arbeit, dass man einmal im Monat Geld bekommt.
Stimmt, das war von Sony, genau, sogar von Sony.
Also, das ist halt echt so ein Ding.
Wir sind falsch, na, ich weiß nicht, das...
Naja.
So, das ist auch so ein Ding, ne?
Hier seien die Vorstellungen...
Jetzt kommt die 0815 Personalabteilungsbegründung schlechthin, da sie nicht zum gewachsenen Gehaltsgefüge des Unternehmens passen.
Also, das Unternehmen, was mit sowas anfängt, muss sich auf zwei Sachen einstellen können.
Das erste ist, dass neue Leute nicht dort anfangen.
Und das zweite ist, dass immer mehr alte Leute abhauen, die sie nicht durch neue Leute besetzen können.
Es sei denn, sie überdenken mal ihr gewachsenes Gehaltsgefüge.
Das heißt nicht nur, dass man vielleicht den neuen Bewerbern etwas entgegenkommen muss mit den Gehaltsvorstellungen.
Nein, man müsste eigentlich auch den anderen Leuten ein bisschen mehr bezahlen, dass sie nicht abhauen.
Und noch ein weiterer Punkt, warum die Vorstellungen der Bewerber falsch sind.
Wo ich auch nochmal widersprechen muss.
Die Bewerber, die haben auch mitgekriegt, dass du mittlerweile 30 Euro für ein größeres Mittagessen in einem Restaurant bezahlen musst.
Also, ich rede jetzt nicht von 0815 Burger oder sowas.
Ich war letztens Mittagessen ganz Gänsebraten.
Und das hat mich insgesamt, glaube ich, 33 Euro pro Portion gekostet.
Also, das haut schon rein.
Also, die Leute haben mittlerweile auch alle mitgekriegt, dass die Wurstpackung Salami nicht mal 50 Cent, sondern 2,50 Euro kostet.
Und dementsprechend, was bleibt den Leuten denn anders übrig, als zu sagen, ich will mehr Geld haben?
Naja.
Also, die müssen halt ihr Gehalt...
Okay, wenn die geforderten Kompetenzen nicht passen, ja, dann verstehe ich es.
Das ist doch das, was ich schon seit der ganzen...
Im Prinzip seit ich streame, schon 580 Mal gesagt.
Wenn du keine Bewerber findest, du kannst drei Sachen machen.
Du kannst die eigenen Vorteile, die es hat, bei dir zu arbeiten, besser verkaufen.
Das heißt, bessere Stellenanzeigen schreiben und das, was du vielleicht sogar echt schon zu bieten hast,
wirklich herausstellen, dich attraktiver machen als Arbeitgeber.
Das kannst du machen.
Du kannst die Leute mit Geld zuscheißen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Oder?
Du kannst deine Ansprüche senken an deine Bewerber.
Realistisch betrachtet, wirst du wahrscheinlich von allen drei Sachen ein bisschen was machen müssen.
Du musst auf anderen Wegen nach Bewerber suchen.
Nicht umsonst in die ganzen Rise of LinkedIn Headhunters, die die letzten Jahre über.
Oder du machst dich, das ist die vierte Option.
Du musst wahrscheinlich auch ein paar Leuten mal eine Chance geben,
die nicht nach 15 Jahren Kubernetes-Erfahrung, was es erst seit zwölf Jahren gibt, haben.
Wobei, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, Kubernetes gibt es seit 2009 oder so.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Gibt es sogar schon.
Ich hätte gedacht, es gibt es sogar schon ein bisschen länger.
Aber 2009 war es dann eher Docker.
Noch nicht Kubernetes.
Ja, du hast recht.
Das kann überhaupt nicht 2009 sein.
Ja, noch besser.
Also, du wirst wahrscheinlich beides machen.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich ein bisschen deine eigenen Ansprüche runterschrauben müssen.
Du wirst ein bisschen mehr Geld bezahlen müssen.
Und du wirst gewisse Anreize bieten müssen, was ja nicht unbedingt nur der Obstkorb ist.
Oder wenn du welche hast, die einfach besser verkaufen müssen.
Die müssen, gerade Personalabteilung habe ich den Eindruck,
das ist dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, ist das tatsächlich schon so semi-gut, finde ich.
Also man sieht, die haben dort die letzten Jahre über echt aufgeholt.
Also wenn du die Stellenanzeigen mal vergleichst,
dann sind die mittlerweile echt, also wenn ich die Stellenanzeigen von dem, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
vergleich mit den Stellenanzeigen vom letzten, da sind die, wo ich jetzt arbeite, tatsächlich deutlich besser.
Aber auch, aber auch noch nicht so, wo ich sagen würde, ey, den rennen sie jetzt die Bude ein.
Aber na gut.
Aber das müssen, glaube ich, auch viele Personalabteilungen oder also Recruiterleute lernen,
dass es halt nicht damit getan ist, einfach mal eine Stellenanzeige 0 auf 15 rauszukloppen, sondern man muss sich, wie bei einer
Bewerbung, tatsächlich Gedanken machen, wie man das macht.
Was in 41 Prozent der Fälle fehlt, ist an notwendigen Softskills.
Wie stellen die das denn fest?
Nötige Softskills, ist das dann, wenn sie irgendwie einen der blöden Vorstellungsfragen nicht beantworten können, so nach dem Motto, wie viele Smarties passen in einen Smart?
Und, und der Bewerber sagt dann, ey, geht mir nicht auf den Sack.
Okay, da würde ich auch sagen, bei der Aussage, dem fehlen die nötigen Softskills.
Das kann man ein bisschen passender verpacken, ja.
Paul, danke für den Sub.
Also, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Softskills in der, äh, ja, jo, danke für den Sub, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Exzellente Subscriptions, Leute.
Also ich würde eher sagen, die Softskills der IT-Leute hat die letzten 10 Jahre enorm zugenommen.
Früher waren die Kellerkinder wie ehemalig.
Ich, normal, heute hast du tatsächlich Leute, die, ähm, im Sommer auch, äh, leicht gebräunten Hauttonen haben, weil sie nicht nur im Keller vorm Computer sitzen.
Und dementsprechend auch nicht durchdrehen, wenn sie drei Sätzen mit, äh, Leuten wechseln müssen.
Also ich würde sagen, die letzten 10 Jahre hat, hat, hat das schon zugenommen.
35% fehlen die nötigen Deutschkenntnisse.
Okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Das weiß ich nur vom alten Arbeitgeber.
Da haben sich total viele, auch auf LinkedIn und sowas, haben sich total viele Inder beworben.
Letztens habe ich gehört, es hat sich, äh, ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen, die haben sich voll verarscht.
Ich hab's mal erzählt, aber ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen.
Es hat sich bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber, hat sich eine aus Indien beworben, die auch nicht richtig Deutsch kann.
Und, ich krieg die Story nicht mehr, ich hab, ich hab die euch erzählt, die Story, als sie frisch war.
Jetzt hab ich's vergessen.
Ähm, irgendwie haben sie die aber auch richtig jebaited mit der Stelle.
Naja, aber das kann ich schon insofern verstehen, wenn du dir teilweise auf LinkedIn anguckst, irgendwelche Posts, und da unten drunter steht dann,
ich bin Peter vom Microsoft Gold Support aus Indien, ich möchte bei ihnen anfangen.
Und das steht natürlich nicht so schön da.
Ja, dann, da kann ich das verstehen.
So nach dem Motto, ich hab keine Erfahrung darin, aber ich habe schon mal Word aufgemacht.
Jo, danke für den Sub.
Ja.
Personalberater beklagen zum Beispiel überzogene Wunschlisten von Unternehmen.
Das haben wir auch schon öfters in Vorstellungsgesprächen gesehen, ey.
Na gut, wie dem auch sei.
Oh, weiter.
Ja, das ist natürlich, auf der einen Seite finde ich's blöd, auf der anderen Seite irgendwie auch verständlich.
Ich, ich bin der Meinung, das sind so Sachen, die muss man halt einfach mal ausprobieren, weil in der aktuellen Zeit hast du halt echt Probleme, zu sagen, wir machen alles so wie immer, das klappt schon.
Weil es klappt halt offensichtlich nicht.
Deswegen, ich denke, so Sachen muss man einfach, auch wenn man denkt, dass es Probleme geben kann, ich verstehe die Einwände ja auch, finde ich, sollte man es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und vielleicht klappt's ja wirklich wieder erwartend gut.
Schon hat man festgestellt.
Man kann auch ohne Probleme englischsprachige Bewerber nehmen.
Wir hatten einen aus, äh, ich glaub, aus Kamerun?
Oder Elf-, ich glaub, wir hatten, äh, Elfenbeinküste kam der her.
Wir hatten mal einen aus der Elfenbein, also von, von, äh, sagt man aus der Elfenbeinküste, von der Elfenbeinküste?
Nein, man sagt heute einfach aus Elfenbeinküste, Alter.
Also, der kam aus Elfenbeinküste und der konnte am Anfang nur Französisch.
Ähm, Englisch und ein bisschen Deutsch, so ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wenig Deutsch.
Und das Erste, was er irgendwie gelernt hat, auf Deutsch zu sagen, das ist das, was er sagen darf, ja, aber wenn das einer von uns, von uns gesagt hätte, wäre es, er hätte es richtig Probleme gegeben.
Der, der hat immer, der hat immer gesagt, der jetzt, also eines der ersten Sachen, der, die, die er gelernt hat, ist irgendwie sowas, wer hat Angst vorm schwarzen Mann?
Der war, war komplett schwarzer, ja.
Und da hat er immer gesagt.
Achtung, der schwarze Mann kommt, als er ins Büro ist.
Und irgendwie fand er das lustig.
Und wir haben uns immer gedacht, okay, wir dürfen nicht anfangen, das auch zu sagen, weil ansonsten, ansonsten ist das, ähm, sehr fragwürdig schon.
Ansonsten wäre das, wäre das enorm monkatos, ja.
Dann hat er immer gesagt, Achtung, der schwarze Mann kommt, oder so Zeug.
Der fand das lustig.
Da sieht man mal wieder, wie unterschiedlich das ist, wer was sagt.
Wie es auf, wie es aufgenommen wird, ja.
Das ist ein bisschen so, wenn, wenn ich mich als Dicker hinsetze und irgendwelche Witzereien über Dicke, dann sagt man auch, ja gut, der Dicke labert halt.
Wenn ich das aber abfällig mache als, ähm, super, super krass trainierter Dude, dann wirkt das schon wieder ganz anders.
Alles klar.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Okay, den heißen Artikel haben wir.
Da gucken wir uns, wir, wir hatten das hier, irgendjemand hat doch hier gepostet.
TopConWD1, also das ist schon mal richtig HighIQ Webadresse.
Kann sich definitiv noch keiner merken.
Ähm, also.
Das erste, was mich verwirrt ist, dass das Intro auf Englisch ist und der Rest auf Deutsch.
Das finde ich nicht schlimm, aber wahrscheinlich ist das einfach Copy-Paste.
Das ist das, was überall davor steht und man hofft vielleicht auch den einen oder anderen, der ein bisschen Englisch reden kann.
Das ist aber doch eine Stille.
Boah, jetzt geht's aber.
Alter, was ihr, das, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Wenn ich so weiter renne, ja, dann ist, dann ist bei mir, ich hab ja schon fast unter 90 Kilo jetzt, man.
Also, wir gucken das mal schnell durch.
TopCon Electronics ist ein produzierendes im, im Geisenheim-Rheingau nahe Wiesbaden.
Okay.
Also, sie suchen einen IT-Systemadministrator.
Ich find's ja cool, dass noch Leute so die Klassiker suchen.
IT-Systemadministrator.
Keine Side-Reliability-Engine.
Ingenieurs, DevOps, FiveHeads, BISSEC, WinOps-Leute waren einfach nur ein richtig oldschool IT-Systemadministrator.
Okay, du bist verantwortlich für Design, Analyse, Bewertung.
Also, auf den ersten Blick würde ich sagen, ist enorm viel Text, aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt schlecht sein.
Design, Analyse, Bewertung, Tests, Bereitstellung.
Jetzt geht's rein.
Das ist ja hier der Richtige.
Design, Analyse, Bewertung, Tests, Bereitstellung, Installation, Konfiguration, Betrieb und Wartung.
Bam, bababam, ey, da geht's Schlager auf Schlager.
Und von IT-System, Hardware, Software und zugehörigen Tools, Infrastruktur, unterstützt, Engineering, Softwareentwicklung und Produktionsumgebung.
Das würde ich irgendwie kürzen.
Das ist super kompliziert geschrieben.
Man versteht, was gemeint ist.
Sie beteiligen sich an der technischen Forschung und Entwicklung,
um kontinuierlich Innovationen innerhalb der Infrastruktur zu ermöglichen.
Es ist sicher, dass alle Hardware, Betriebssysteme, Software und zugehörige Verfahren
den organisatorischen und betrieblichen Richtlinien und Standards entsprechen.
Das ist mega förmlich geschrieben.
Das, kann man das, also ich fände es ansprechender, wenn das irgendwie kurz und knackiger dastehen würde.
Und ich glaube auch gar nicht, dass das so gemeint ist mit technischen Forschung und Entwicklung.
Du bist kein Science-Typ, der irgendwelche Sachen erforscht.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, die meinen damit Erprobung von neuen Sachen.
Ja.
Von neuen Sachen, die sich eignen könnten für die.
Nicht irgendwie, ihr entwickelt jetzt, ihr macht jetzt was eigenes.
So nach dem Motto, wir könnten ja auch mal Ubuntu anstatt Red Hat ausprobieren.
Sowas in der Richtung ist damit gemeint.
Gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Ob das jetzt, das ist halt super kompliziert geschrieben.
Es wirkt ein bisschen wie aus Chat-GPT.
Ja, gebe ich dir recht.
Sie übernehmen die tägliche Unterstützung von Systemendiensten einschließlich Windows, Mac,
und Linux.
Ihr habt Linux-Workstations, nicht schlecht, Pluspunkt.
Aber das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, oder?
Ich meine, ihr habt, ihr wollt einen Admin, der sich um alle möglichen Server, Hardware, Software und sonst wie
Analyse, Design, Test, Bereitstellung, Installation, Konfiguration kümmert.
Dann soll er mitarbeiten und gucken, wie man eure Sache zukunftssicher machen kann.
Dann macht er nebenbei noch täglichen Support von Windows.
Windows, Mac, Linux, mobilen Endgeräten, Windows, ist das eine, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein, oder?
Mein mobilen Smartphone, Windows, Linux, Cloud, nicht Cloud, das ist doch eine, das ist doch, das ist doch, okay, Leute, ich, ich, ich glaube am Ende, ich, ich glaube, das ist, das ist, das ist eine, das ist eine Anzeige.
Da steht am Ende, und auch wenn du das nicht kannst, bist du trotzdem willkommen.
So nach dem Motto.
Das ist bestimmt so ein G-Bait, oder?
Hast du eigentlich nicht dein Linux jetzt bekommen, bei, also halb, so halb, ich hab nur 4M mit Linux drauf, ja.
Aber das ist ja krass, das ist ja aber wirklich alles in einem, das ist ja schon so übertrieben, das muss ich ja fast speichern, das muss man ja irgendwo mal zeigen, ne.
Das ist ja richtig krass, man.
Windows, Mac und Linux Workstations, mobilen Smartphone-Geräten, Windows und Linux-Servern, Cloud und nicht Cloud, physisch und virtuell Netzwerk, Backup-Tools, Überwachung, CAD?
What the fuck?
Zusammenarbeit, Konfiguration, Konfiguration.
Das ist doch, das ist doch garantiert ein Trick, oder? Das ist doch garantiert ein Trick.
Ne, das ist kein Trick.
Ich hab gedacht, da kommt am Ende sowas wie, und jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn dich IT interessiert, dann komm zu uns.
Sie benötigen Kenntnisse über Systemdesigns für Serverkomponenten einschließlich Prozessoren fest...
Das ist doch ein Witz, das muss ein Witz sein, Leute, das kann nicht sein.
Das kann, das muss ein Witz sein.
Das muss ein Witz sein, das, das, das glaube ich nicht.
Sie benötigen Kenntnisse über Systemdesigns für Serverkomponenten einschließlich Prozessoren, Festplatten-Arrays, Speicherbetriebs- und sowie Cloud-basierter Datenverarbeitung und Speicherung zugehören.
Sie übernehmen die Verantwortung für die Verwaltung, für die Verwaltung, Überwachung und Sicherung der Infrastruktur, eigentlich der Produktionsanlagen, Wartung, Aktualisierung, Implementation von vorhandenen neuen Server für Windows- und Linux-Systeme.
Je nach Anforderung.
Bei der Entwicklung und Einführung von Anwendungen, Ihre Arbeit schneller und effizienter zu gestalten, geht Recherche, Implementierung und Testung von neuer Software in allen Bereichen einen Mehrwert von...
Sie kommunizieren mit den Kollegen an den internationalen Standorten, Ausbildung, Alter, Fädel, ich finde das sab...
Studiengang, Bachelor of Science, ähnliche drei Jahre Ausbildung, Fachum...
fach idealerweise windows office gutes verständnis netzwerk speicher cloud
basierte infrastruktur disaster recovery wartung beheben windows linux server
computer mit betriebssystem zu versteht und kann ip netzwerk konzepte anwenden
switching routing entwickelt dokumentiert implementiert sorgt für die
einhaltung unternehmens richtigen verfahren bleiben sie über die neusten
auf dem laufenden fähigkeit als also ich warte immer noch auf den witz am
ende soja verfolgen und verwalten von arbeitsaufzeichnungen was kenntnis in
ms ce cloud platform schulung mcs a linux
foundation
certified windows escher vm wm linux verschiedene betriebe des centos ubuntu
linux windows 2012 server container lesen verschieden die sind ein
enthusiastischer autonomer praxisorientierter serviceorientiert
der fachmann fachfrau mit ausgeprägten allison gesicht sprechen fiesen
überholt schrift der reảng sehr kollegiales team geprägt von
gemeinschaft sind home office ist möglich bringen sie gerne eigentlich
eigentlich
habe ich gedacht, am Ende
kommt jetzt hier die
Auflösung. Ich dachte,
am Ende steht hier ein Satz drin.
Und jetzt mal
ernsthaft,
wir suchen
sie trotzdem so. Irgendwie sowas.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
ich dachte eigentlich, das ist so eine G-Bait-Anzeige.
Was?
Alter.
Ihr übertreibt's leicht, gell?
Wer hat die Anzeige noch gepostet?
Jojo.
Ist das von...
Das ist von euch, ja?
Das ist aber übertrieben, Mann.
Ihr findet doch niemand
dafür. Zwar ernsthaft.
Also, wenn ihr jemand findet, dann
niemand, der dieser Anforderung hier entspricht.
Und...
Jojo, kannst du ungefähr eine Gehaltsspanne
sagen?
Würde mich einfach mal interessieren,
was die dafür bieten.
Wahrscheinlich
50k.
Gibt's hier noch mehr?
Haben die noch mehr so tolle
Dinger?
Oder
die suchen eigentlich 5 Leute und haben alles
in eine gepackt. Ja, das könnte natürlich auch
sein. Also, das
ist ja heftig, Mann.
MonkaS, Alter.
Komm, wir gucken mal ein YouTube-Video
zur Abwechslung.
Wir haben noch 2 Stellenanzeigen auf, aber das können wir
auch als nächstes mal machen.
Aber das ist ja heftig.
Also, da muss ich ehrlich sagen,
also,
so übertrieben
habe ich in letzter Zeit selten was
gesehen. Also,
habe ich schon. Ja, manche haben es noch mehr
übertrieben. Aber das war
nur wirklich schon komplett. Das gibt's
dafür ein Wort. So
Requirements-Bombing oder sowas. Gibt's
dafür irgendein Wort? Also, das ist ja quasi,
wir wollen alles haben.
Ah. Eric,
das habe ich mir jetzt ausgedacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das Wort
gibt.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
So, komm, wir gucken uns mal. Wir gucken, wir, lasst
uns mal ein Video zwischendurch mal angucken.
Haben wir denn?
Nee.
Dark Side of Open Source.
Was ist die Dark Side of Open Source?
Oh, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das war, das ist irgendein
Chromefrog. Also, ich kann euch
nur das erzählen, was ich mit, was ich mitbekommen habe.
Ähm, das habe ich irgendwo auf Reddit gelesen oder auf
Hacker-News, glaube ich, habe ich das irgendwo gelesen.
Und zwar, Thorium ist wohl
ein Chromefrog.
Nur, dass der Typ, der diesen,
der das betreut,
der das betreut auf GitHub,
hat irgendwelchen Furry-Porn
oder sowas eingecheckt
in das Repo.
Das habe ich mitbekommen.
Ich glaube, auf Hacker-News
oder Reddit, ich weiß nicht genau.
Der hat
irgendwelche Furry-Porn,
irgendwelche Furry-Sachen eingecheckt
in das Repo
von seinem Chromefrog.
Ja, keine Ahnung,
was mit dem abkippt, weil
das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Deswegen habe ich es auch gelesen.
Fragt man sich halt nur,
wie sowas passieren kann. Ist das absichtlich
drinne? Hat er sich,
hat er cp'et ins falsche Verzeichnis?
Falsch gesynct?
Weil irgendwo
muss das ja mal committed haben, ne?
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht on-stream an.
Ich habe es mir auch nicht off-stream angeguckt.
Ich habe das nur gelesen.
Ich will das jetzt nicht aufmachen on-stream
in dem Fall der Fälle,
dass das TOS ist.
Komm, wir gucken uns das mal an.
Vielleicht hat er ein bisschen mehr Infos.
Ich habe das nur ganz am Rande
mitbekommen, dass es in irgendeinem
Chromium-Frog irgendwie Furry-Porn
gab.
A couple months ago, I recommended a browser
called Thorium.
Thorium, from a technical aspect,
was fantastic for me personally.
It was the best web browser for me.
They even titled that video
the best web browser.
And it got circulated, went viral,
almost, I think well over
half a million views now.
Just a huge...
Hätte man durch den Schnee gestelzt mit dem Browser,
dann wären es 2,2 Millionen Views gewesen.
Huge success from a video standpoint
and also I thought it was a win-win.
Everybody was enjoying things.
But if you look down there
at the title of this video,
it's called the dark side of open source
because, well, there hasn't been any security
breach and the project itself
is kind of in limbo right
now because of
some political choices and also
just
disappearing too, which we need
to talk about. All these
different things... Na gut, wahrscheinlich ist der Maintainer
abgehauen, nachdem er aus dem Furry-Porn
eingecheckt hatte in seinem Browser.
Das war ihm vielleicht ein bisschen peinlich, könnte ja auch sein.
...that have happened
and
why I'm no longer using it.
And also it just kind of left a
really bad taste in my mouth
and this is one of the downsides
to open source that
you can run into.
I still love open source, still recommend a lot
of open source projects, but
I definitely will be much more
happy... Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Problem
von open source ist, wenn halt
ein Entwickler auf Furry-Porn steht und
aus Versehen Sachen bei sich in
das Repo committed hat. Das ist ja kein...
Okay, du könntest sagen, es ist insofern ein Problem
von open source, weil es jeder sehen kann.
Ja...
Besser, du kannst die Möglichkeit
das festzustellen, anstatt
du machst Ausweis in die Software auf,
klickst auf About und dann kommt dann irgendein
keine Ahnung...
irgendein Viech halt, ne?
... hesitant to recommend
the next open source project
in the future without
really, really
vetting it to an extent.
Even though I've used Thorium, still haven't
installed it...
... places here and there that I haven't
quite gotten to to uninstall it yet.
It's not because of some
vast security flaw
or some crazy bug that came out.
So let's get into this, I'm gonna jump
on the desktop. We gotta talk about
is it maintained
anymore?
Some things that got slipped in there
or illicit material
I would say...
Just overall what has happened
and to the
developer as well.
It's just...
It's just a damn shame. So let's get into it
and get on the desktop.
Wo hab ich denn mein MonkaTOS-Bild?
Ah, hier, hier ist es.
Ich muss das nämlich raussuchen,
weil das werde ich jetzt bestimmt
öfters mal brauchen. Im Zweifelsfall
auch um irgendwas... Na gut, es ist auf YouTube,
da wird nichts Schlimmes drin zu sehen sein.
So, let's look at the source code
here with the Thorium project.
It actually has recently been updated.
If we look at the recent
commits, you can see...
Remove offending image!
In the last 13 to 14 hours we've seen
some new commits, and
the last commit before that was November 3rd.
So we had some period of inactivity...
Ich würde jetzt zu gerne, Leute,
ich würde zu gerne in die
History von diesem Repo gehen und
schauen, was das
offending image ist. Aber das
kann ich nicht on stream machen,
weil das wahrscheinlich MonkaTOS ist.
Ich muss... Oh, Leute,
ich muss jetzt...
Ich muss auf... Ich guck jetzt im...
Ich guck jetzt im zweiten Tab, was das ist.
Remove offending image.
Äh...
Ist gar nicht so wild!
Das dürfte man heutzutage
sogar auf Twitch zeigen, wenn man
in die Art-Kategorie switcht.
Ja?
Chat, ich muss den Stream kurz
auf Art umstellen, dann
darf ich das zeigen.
Artistik. Pass mal auf,
wir müssen die neue Kategorie jetzt auch mal benutzen.
Für irgendwas, okay? Also...
Ähm, nee, komm,
scheiß drauf. Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Was? Wie?
Wait, what?
Ernsthaft?
Können die sich... Hey, Alter, hätten die sich
das nicht vorher überlegen können, Mann?
Oh Mann.
Na gut. Ähm, es ist...
Okay, seriously, Leute, das Bild
ist echt nicht so wild, was da drin
gewesen ist. Ich hab das gerade im zweiten...
Ich hab im zweiten Tab geguckt. Also,
man sieht dort...
Ich würde sagen,
ein...
Reh?
Vermutlich.
Ein sehr menschlich
aussehendes Reh,
wo halt der Hintern
von unten fotografiert
ist, okay?
Kann sich jeder vorstellen, was
das da Sache ist.
Was war da drinne?
A lot of people were pinging me, saying, hey,
why hasn't, uh, you know,
Chrome 118
been released? And I was like, hey, don't worry,
it's in pre-stage, I'm sure that's
gonna be pushed out soon, he's probably just
vetting and stripping some stuff out, so
it would be great, uh, for this.
But then he kind of went inactive for
about the past month. Wie viel Sterne hatten
das eigentlich?
Wie viel Sterne hatten das eigentlich?
3,3k.
Until today. And then I was like, oh,
removing a fending image
in an update version, that both
sounds like good things
for this browser.
And then I got more people pinging me
and other YouTubers making videos about
Thorium, and then I was like, okay,
let me do a deeper dive into the code. Wie viele Tabs hast du bitte offen?
Naja, da hab ich Tabs offen,
und da hab ich Tabs offen.
Und altertief hab ich da auch noch ein paar Tabs
offen, und in meiner VM auch.
Irgendwie musste meine 64 GB RAM ja hin.
It's not my generation, it's just kind of weird.
But apparently there was
Y-I-F-F stuff
in the browser, and
uh, it was like a hidden...
Was? Y-I-F-F?
Was ist
Y-I-F-F?
Oder, oder
with? Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich danach googeln darf.
Vorhin, ich muss das
offscreen machen.
Y-I-F-F meaning, okay.
Y-I-F-F.
Y-I-F-F is a slang term used in the
furry fandom
to refer to pornographic
content. Aha.
Alles klar.
An Easter egg in there,
and people made issues about it.
Uh, specifically here,
and then I actually looked up one of the
older ones from archive,
and sorry for the flashbang here, but
it just kind of goes in, hey,
why was there this stuff hidden in the about page,
and then people got to exactly
what it was. I looked at the image from it,
and it wasn't like super
bad, but at the same time very
suggestive, uh,
cartoon bunny, I think is the best
way to put it. Also, einen Hase?
Ich hätte eher gedacht, das war ein Reh.
Chatke, für alle, die es
gesehen haben, meint ihr, das war ein
Hase oder ein Reh? Ich würde
sagen, das war ein Reh.
Muss ja da korrekt sein jetzt an der
Stelle, ja? And I was
like, alright, well, I didn't know that was a thing,
why would you put that in your browser?
That's weird. And then,
it went and
took a completely
really dark turn from that.
I was just about to excuse that.
Hey, that's just weird.
He'll remove it, I'm sure it'll be fine.
And then I saw
anti-CRC stuff put
on another site or something.
Apparently his political views
are more about anti-
Alter, warum checkt er sowas?
Alter, was mit den Leuten los, man?
And had
pictures detailing that process
and why apparently you shouldn't?
I don't know. I didn't
get into it. I looked at that enough and
I was like, oh my gosh.
What a nightmare. What a
complete nightmare. So he had this
commitment. Da ist sicherlich auch mal ganz
schnell die Grenze zu, ihr wisst
schon was, überschritten.
Ich will das Wort jetzt nicht sagen, weil man weiß
nicht, was da für Filter alle mitlaufen und sowas.
Da ist die Grenze
sicherlich ganz schnell mal überschritten.
Committed to
the main branch of thorium under
the MISC folder.
I think there was like a misclick or maybe
he copied that in.
Hat er das alles random
auf seiner Platte verteilt, dass es zufällig
spawnt in seinem Git-Repo oder wie?
...actual binary
files or anything, so I had to do
some digging to find this stuff
and then obviously it showed in
this recent commit where he deleted
all of it, which
yeah, like why would you put that
on a project? So between the
YIFF stuff and then the
circumcision stuff, I was like
oh my gosh, how can this get
worse? And
then I got on Twitter and
Brody commented a whole bunch on that.
And it kind of went through
this weird rabbit hole
and people started jumping to conclusions
like the internet does, calling
it child PORN.
And that
was just, it's not what it was.
And I
That escalated quickly.
I wanted to just kind of call this down
before the internet spiraled out of control
and started ruining
this guy's life because of his
sexual preferences and his politics,
which one,
he made a big mistake
obviously, and I just aired out
those mistakes as far as I can see them
from a
analytical point of view. This is just
very hard stuff to talk about, especially
on YouTube. The guy's 22
years old and I just
I mean,
du musst sowas
wirklich aktiv committen,
wenn es noch nicht drinne ist.
Es reicht ja nicht, wenn du
einfach jetzt aus Versehen das
Verzeichnis reinkopierst,
dann musst du danach zumindest noch mal ein git add
auf das Verzeichnis machen oder zumindest
ein git add minus groß A auf das gesamte Projekt
und so, zumal es ja auch quasi
im Anführungszeichen richtigen Ordner
lag für zusätzliche
Sachen, also
git add Punkt reicht nicht,
git add Punkt, achso, doch,
reicht, reicht, reicht, reicht auch.
Deswegen sollte man das ja auch
nicht machen. Wobei ich mir bei
git add Punkt nicht sicher bin, ob das reicht
für untracked files,
wahrscheinlich, ja.
Hey, okay,
das Internet, das Internet ist mal wieder
zugange.
...
Also ich würde, Leute, Leute, Leute, geht auf gar keinen Fall in das Git-Repo und guckt euch in der History das an.
Also nicht das Furry-Bild, wenn ihr auf sowas steht, guckt es euch an, meinetwegen.
Aber die anderen Bilder, auf gar keinen Fall, ich weiß nicht, was da drauf zu sehen ist.
Und sollte das problematischer Content mit Kindern sein, um es mal so zu umschreiben,
dann ist das bei euch in der Browser-History und in eurem Cache und sonst was habt ihr im Zweifelsfall Probleme.
Geht auf gar keinen Fall auf das Git-Repo und klickt irgendwelche Sachen an.
Warum?
Da kann er doch nichts davon.
Dafür, wenn er das Projekt, also das sehe ich jetzt bei ihm ja überhaupt kein Problem.
Wenn er den Browser benutzt und er denkt, das ist ein guter Browser, hat gute Änderungen drin, die was für ihn sind,
der kann doch nicht ernsthaft wissen, dass da irgendwelches random Zeug in dem Git-Repo eingecheckt ist.
Ich meine, woher soll er das wissen?
Er hat weniger als, du weißt, mehrere tausend Commits und hat mindestens 20 Kollaboratoren,
oder vielleicht mindestens 100 Kollaboratoren als Minimum.
Da kann er doch nichts für.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Er hat mindestens 20 Kollaboratoren oder vielleicht mindestens 100 Kollaboratoren als Minimum.
Es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich definitiv ein riesiger Verderbring für viele Open Source,
und getestet wie das nach der Empfehlung es Leuten für was weiß.
Da kann er, da kann er doch echt nichts für.
Und das muss ja kein schlechter Browser sein, nur durch das da, dass da auf einmal Furry-Porn drin ist.
Trotzdem weird, ganz merkwürdiges Zeug.
Das Internet hat wieder zugeschlagen, anders kann man das glaube ich nicht umschreiben.
Jetzt, wobei.
Wobei.
Er muss sagen, er hieß früher auch anders.
Bilde ich mir ein, zumindest.
Früher hatte er einen längeren Namen.
Oder wir haben noch jemanden, der einen ähnlichen Namen hat.
Ich glaube, er hieß früher noch anders.
Nightbot immer noch kaputt.
Wieso? Geht doch.
Nightbot scheint zu funktionieren.
Warum ist er kaputt?
Er geht doch.
Er schreibt sowas, Nightbot.
Und Informatik studieren.
Tja, wenn man sich das wirklich zumut.
Weil das Command anders ausschauen sollte.
Die Modgis machen das.
Ich kann das ändern, wahrscheinlich im Webinterface vom Nightbot.
Was sollte denn da jetzt drinne stehen?
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Also ehrlich gesagt ist mir der Titel fast schon zu G-Bait mäßig, weil das Blödsinn ist.
Was ist das?
Der Auer!
Von dem haben wir schon lange nix mehr geguckt.
Was ist das?
Unsere Lieblingsgadgets. Last-Minute-Geschenke-Tipps.
Nächstes Wochenende ist schon Weihnachten, man.
Das ging dieses Jahr echt schnell, man.
Ging echt schnell rum.
Mit Chainlord, das war klar, dass du bei sowas am Start bist.
Unsere Lieblingsgadgets. Last-Minute-Geschenktipps.
Okay, gucken wir mal. Vielleicht ist da irgendwas dabei.
Was hältst du von den freien Cisco-Kursen wie Networking Basics?
Ich kenne die freien Cisco-Kurse nicht.
Ich habe vor Urzeiten, das ist wirklich, das ist schon mindestens 10 Jahre her.
Ne, das ist 15 Jahre her.
Habe ich den CCNA gemacht.
Und die Cisco-Dinger sind halt enorm Cisco-spezifisch und auch viel auswendig lernen so.
Wie mache ich das halt auf Networking Basics?
Auf einem Cisco-Gerät.
Du kriegst zwar auch ein bisschen Netzwerksachen drum herum beigebracht, aber es war alles äußerst Cisco-spezifisch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die freien Kurse sind, wahrscheinlich genauso.
Aber eines der Sachen, die bei Cisco wirklich nice ist, ist der Packet Tracer.
Den es ja auch immer noch kostenlos gibt, wenn man sich einen Account macht.
Packet Tracer ist wirklich geil zum Nachgucken, wie Sachen netzwerktechnisch funktionieren.
Ne, finde ich nicht.
Hier brauchst du noch 4Ms.
Und brauchst du Switch-Firmwares und solche Geschichten.
Das ist vielleicht gut, wenn du damit komplexere Sachen oder vielleicht sogar Real-World-Sachen irgendwie simulieren willst oder so.
Aber rein zu Educational-Zwecken finde ich Packet Tracer immer noch das Beste.
So, gucken wir mal.
Last-Minutes-Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Guck mal hier, das bin ich, wie ich kurz vor Weihnachten noch versuche, panisch irgendwelche Geschenke zu finden.
Wisst ihr, was mich das erinnert?
Das Video finde ich leider nicht mehr.
Als im Mediamarkt, also als World of Warcraft rausgekommen ist,
beziehungsweise ich glaube das erste World of Warcraft Addon rausgekommen ist,
da gab es ein Video, wo die Leute im Mediamarkt standen, nachts und die Scheibe zerbrochen ist,
weil zu viele Leute sich reingequetscht haben.
Also es müsste dann irgendwie 2007 oder so gewesen sein.
Nee, nee, nee, Moment.
World of Warcraft kam 2004, glaube ich, raus.
Das war dann wahrscheinlich 2006 oder so.
Da sind dann die Scheiben geplatzt beim Mediamarkt.
Falls ihr das kennt, dieses Video ist für euch.
Das 3003-Team, also Shahin, Lukas, Pascal und ich, zeigen euch unsere ganz persönlichen Geschenke.
Alles wirklich mit viel Liebe ausgesucht.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hexen.
Herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von...
NordVPN.
...Incogni.
InCogni ist ein Dienst, der automatisch eure persönlichen Daten aus den Fängen von Datenhändlern befreit.
Ja, es gibt leider hunderte von Datenhändlern, die eure Daten entweder...
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, ob das so funktioniert.
...egal oder sogar illegal aus irgendwelchen Servereinbrüchen bekommen haben und die dann verkaufen.
Falls ihr euch manchmal wundert, warum in Spam-Mails euer voller Name steht...
Ja, womöglich gekauft von Datenhändlern.
Mit DSGVO und Co. gibt es zwar die Möglichkeit, einer Datennutzung zu widersprechen, da aber dann...
Ja, das interessiert den... genau.
Das interessiert die China-Chinesen-Seite, die meine Daten gesammelt hat, interessiert die DSGVO sicherlich sehr.
...müsstet ihr halt jede einzelne Firma anschreiben.
Incogni nimmt euch diese Arbeit ab und löscht euch vollautomatisch...
Ach, so was ist das.
Das mag funktionieren, aber nur bei denen, wo es wahrscheinlich eh nicht so schlimm ist, dass sie die Daten haben.
...aus hundert...
Okay, aber...
...von Daten...
Macht durchaus Sinn.
...hier, so sieht das dann in der...
Könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Macht durchaus Sinn.
Das bedeutet nämlich, dass ihr bei diesen Datenhändlern...
Aber ich hätte da trotzdem keinen Bock drauf, das machen zu lassen.
...auf der nie wieder irgendwas von mir speichern Liste steht.
Und das ist doch nice.
Wenn ihr das auch wollt, mit dem Coupon-Code CT3003 bekommt ihr unter incogni.com slash ct3003...
Yep, incogni.
...das sind 60% Rabatt aufs Jahresamt.
Werbung Ende.
So, meine persönlichen Geschenkempfehlungen.
Nummer 1...
Nachher hat der Dienst eure Daten.
Naja, irgendein Tod musste sterben, ne?
...Flipper Zero.
Ja, Mensch, ich kann einfach nicht anders, als dieses zuckersüße Hacking-Tool Flipper Zero als meinen ersten Geschenktipp zu empfehlen.
Das haben sogar schon Leute im Stream öfters erwähnt, dass das nice ist.
Vor allem, weil der endlich mal wieder ganz normal für 165 Euro im offiziellen...
Schnapper!
...Webshop erhältlich ist.
Lange Zeit war der sehr schwierig zu kriegen.
Und jetzt mal von der Funktionalität abgesehen, das Teil sieht einfach total super aus, finde ich.
Jetzt nicht nur das Gehäusedesign, sondern auch diese kleinen, charmanten Animationen mit diesem Hacker-Delfin.
Ich finde das einfach...
Ja, und funktional kann das Ding halt auch...
Ein Hacker-Delfin.
...eine Menge mehr, als noch in unserem Testvideo gezeigt.
Es gibt auch ganz viele unterschiedliche Alternativ-Firmwares.
Auf was basiert denn der? Was ist denn da drinnen für ein Controller? Weiß das jemand?
Wir können einfach nachgucken.
Wir können einfach nachgucken, was das ist.
Und zwar...
Java? Zeusch?
MBTLS...
STM32...
...ist das.
Okay.
Warum das 165 Euro kostet?
Ja, Entwicklung kostet auch Geld.
Und wer weiß, was da in Hardware alles drin ist.
...Infos dazu verlinkt.
Aber tut mir den Gefallen, macht unterm Weihnachtsbaum damit dann keinen Bluetooth-Spam-Angriff,
sodass auf Android und iOS-Mobilgeräten immer so Meldungen aufpoppen.
Das könnte zu Konflikten führen.
Und das will man ja Weihnachten nicht.
Geschenke-Tipp Nummer 2. Gebrauchte Fin-Clients.
Ich bin ja immer geschockt davon, dass Leute unsere Empfehlungen hier auf dem Channel tatsächlich manchmal kaufen.
Also irgendwie denke ich, oh Gott, wir haben ja hier eine Verantwortung.
Deshalb will ich jetzt mal eine Lanze dafür brechen, gebrauchte Sachen zu kaufen.
Das ist nämlich nicht nur gut für den Planeten, weil...
Was letzte Preis?
...immer noch mehr Zeug produziert wird, sondern auch...
Mein Kurzengel ist dumm, der macht das.
...zum Beispiel Fin-Clients kann man super gut gebraucht kaufen.
Das sind Rechner mit nicht allzu viel Rechenleistung, aber für ganz viele Sachen ausreichend.
Das stimmt.
Zum Beispiel als Emulationskonsole für alte 8- und 16-Bit-Spiele mit Windows-Server, Linux oder als Home-Server.
Da gebe ich ihm recht, dafür ist das eine super Geschichte.
...Server für Pyro...
Oder, wenn man ein bisschen mehr emulieren will, kauft man sich eine Ryzen-basierte Plattform als Mini-PC.
...Edgard Home oder Plex.
Ein echtes Schnäppchen ist der HP-Thema.
E630, den kriegt man oft für schlappe 30 Euro.
Der hat zwar nur eine Dual-Core-CPU, aber man kann da trotzdem einiges mit anschauen.
Ja, mit einer Dual-Core-Kiste, da kannst du alles.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich inklusive N64 und PS1 wahrscheinlich gut mit emulieren.
Eventuell auch noch die ein oder anderen Sachen drüber, aber da wird es dann wahrscheinlich schon problematisch, je nachdem was da genau drin ist.
...Eyehole und Plex zum Beispiel schafft er gleichzeitig als Home-Server.
Deutlich mehr Power haben so ein...
...Izu Futro S740 oder ein Dell Wyze 5070.
Die gibt es mit Quad-Core-CPU, Intel J4105, die noch einigermaßen neu ist.
Gar nicht mal so schlimm.
Gar nicht mal so schlimm, ja genau.
Es gibt auch noch andere Varianten.
Gar nicht mal so übel, was da drin ist.
Die mit J4105 kriegt man mit Glück für 80 Euro, aber ich finde, nuni sind die auch wert.
Alle erwähnten Rechner sind um es passiv gekühlt, was natürlich super ist für Home-Server im Wohnraum.
Da nerven die wenig.
Aber nicht, dass die so stromhungrig sind.
Günstige Thin Clients, auch schon mal ein Video gemacht, guckt ihr hier.
Geschenktipp Nummer 3.
Also gerade die etwas neueren mit dieser J4105, da hatte ich auch mal ein paar Boards, die verbrauchen im Idle, wenn du eine SSD dran hast, irgendwie 6-7 Watt nur.
...Quest 3 oder eine gebrauchte Quest 2.
Ich bin ja Virtual Reality-Fan, deshalb muss das unbedingt mit rein.
Die Meta-Quest-Headsets wären meine Empfehlung, weil die autark funktionieren, aber auch per USB-Kabel oder per WLAN.
Das brauch ich nicht.
Oder mit einem PC gekoppelt werden können.
Also wenn ihr große VR-Sachen wie Half-Life Alyx oder den Microsoft Flight Simulator spielen wollt.
Das Software-Angebot für PC-losen Betrieb ist bei Meta mit riesigem Abstand gegenüber der Konkurrenz am größten.
Das muss man echt so sagen.
Die Quest 3 kostet ab 550 Euro.
Ansonsten wäre auch die Vorgängerin Quest 2 eine Überlegung wert.
Für VR-Chat, genau.
...gibt's gebraucht.
So ab 200 Euro.
Und reicht zum Beispiel zum Boot.
Zum Beispiel zum Beat Saber spielen.
Voll aus.
Und die lässt sich genauso mit PCs koppeln.
Ihr müsst euch allerdings im Klaren sein, dass ihr für die Quest-Nutzung bei Meta einen Account anlegen müsst.
Ja, aber es muss doch, glaube ich, kein Facebook-Account mehr sein, sondern nur ein Meta-Account, wo auch immer da der Unterschied ist.
Mein ultimativer Weihnachtsgeschenke-Tipp ist das Steam Deck.
Also ich hab das Ding jetzt schon seit einem Dreivierteljahr und jetzt schon damit mehr gespielt.
Gibt's da nicht demnächst einen Refresh von?
Ich hab irgendwo was gelesen.
...als mit meiner Switch, die ich mir irgendwann...
Beziehungsweise sollte es dafür nicht bald einen Refresh geben.
...mehr Spiele am PC, aber so Sachen wie Stardew Valley oder No Man's Sky machen einfach auf dem Sofa mehr Spaß als am Schreibtisch.
Und ja, ihr fragt euch jetzt bestimmt, warum kaufst du nicht irgendwann eine Playstation?
Das Ding ist halt, ich hab ja schon so viele Spiele in meiner Steam Library, die ich irgendwann mal gekauft und nie gespielt hab.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt eine Playstation ins Haus hole, dann müsste ich ja alles nochmal kaufen.
Und hätte auch noch zwei getrennte Libraries.
Mit dem Steam Deck kann ich halt meinen angehäuften Pile of Shame einfach gemütlich abarbeiten.
Und dabei bleiben meine Spielstände.
Dank der Steam Cloud auch synchron, falls ich dann doch am PC...
Und das Wichtigste, Arch Linux Based.
...weiterspielen will.
By the way...
Für mich ist das Teil so eine Art Konsole für PC Gamer.
Oder der verlängerte Arm für PC Gamer.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich benutze das Deck 90% der Zeit gedockt an einem Fernseher mit einem PS5 Controller.
Da muss man bei der Performance im Vergleich zu einer Playstation natürlich Abstriche machen.
Aber so mittelalte Spiele wie Dark Souls 3 oder Resident Evil 7 laufen auf höchsten Einstellungen bei 720p mit durchgängig 60 FPS.
Das ist schon nice.
Ich habe sogar das Resident Evil 4 Remake aus diesem Jahr komplett auf dem Steam Deck durchgespielt.
Das lief auf niedrigen Einstellungen mit fast durchgehend 50 bis 60 FPS.
Mit der neuen OLED-Variante gibt es jetzt auch einen größeren Bildschirm mit perfektem Schwarz und bessere Akkulaufzeit durch eine effizientere CPU.
Ein Wechsel lohnt sich dadurch meiner Meinung nach noch nicht.
Dafür müsste Valve schon eine Version mit deutlich mehr Leistung auf den Markt bringen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr dann.
Aber würde ich irgendjemanden beschenken, oder mich selbst, würde ich auf jeden Fall die OLED-Variante wählen.
Die kostet mit 512 GB internem Speicher 569 Euro.
Ich finde, das geht sogar echt in Ordnung.
...TeraByte und entspiegeltem Display 679 Euro.
Das ursprüngliche LCD-Modell gibt es in der kleinsten Version mit 64 GB schon für 369 Euro.
Also, was soll ich sagen? Steam Deck, geil, let's go, frohe Weihnachten.
Mein Weihnachts-Gadget ist vielleicht ein bisschen weniger tech, als ihr jetzt erwartet.
Aber ich muss dir ehrlich sein und von allen technischen Geräten, die mir ins Haus gekommen sind, ist diese LED-Nachttischlampe wirklich das, was ich mit Abstand am meisten verwende.
Und am vielseitigsten verwendet habe.
Die Funktionen sind natürlich erstmal nichts besonderes.
Man kann mit Touch oben das Ganze ein- und ausschalten.
Die Frage ist, wie es mit Home Assistant Integration aussieht.
Wenn man länger drückt, kann man das Ganze hoch- oder runterdimmen.
Der Stiel und der Boden sind jeweils abschraubbar.
Und über einen USB-C-Port kann das Ganze geladen werden.
Und der Akku hält eine halbe Ewigkeit.
In dem Jahr, in dem ich die jetzt verwende, muss ich sie vielleicht vier-, fünfmal laden.
Diese Art Lampe gibt es von mehreren Firmen mit den komplett gleichen Funktionen.
Da könnt ihr dann schauen, welcher Look eurer Bude ist.
Die Kosten sind meistens so zwischen 40 und 60 Euro.
Wobei man natürlich bei AliExpress das Ganze auch für...
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich damit machen sollte.
Ich meine, ich habe überall eine Lampe.
Und dort, wo ich regelmäßig quasi automatisch eine ausschalten muss, werden die entweder, je nachdem, wenn es so eine Standlampe ist,
ist es in irgendeiner remote schaltbaren Steckdose drin.
Oder ich habe was an der Decke, was man schalten kann.
Also 10 Euro plus 15 Euro Versand kaufen könnte.
Nur bekommt man es dann erst nächstes Jahr und nicht zu Weihnachten.
Der Hauptnutzen unterscheidet sich natürlich gar nicht so riesig von einer üblichen Nachttischlampe.
Der größte Unterschied ist nur, dass man sie überall mit hinschleppen kann.
Aber genau da wurde sie eben auch für mich interessant.
Ich lese im Bett alleine, die Lampe kommt auf meiner Seite.
Meine Freundin und ich lesen gleichzeitig.
Wir nehmen einfach die Lampe und stellen sie zwischen uns.
Oder ich will nachts...
Man könnte auch einfach hier hinten an die Wand so ein bisschen Beleuchtung machen.
So zum Beispiel eine LED-Leiste oder so.
Könnte man auch passende Stimmung erzeugen mit dem Licht.
Ich kann jetzt aufs Klo gehen.
Ich habe aber Angst, mir den Zeh zu stoßen, wenn ich im Dunkeln da hinwatsche.
Dann nehme ich sie in die Hand und gehe einfach mit so einer kleinen Lampe ins Bad, als wäre es 1800.
Das waren alles Dinge, die ich auch mal ganz gerne mit der Handytaschenlampe gemacht habe.
Aber für meine geistige Gesundheit versuche ich die Screentime vor dem Schlafen und nach dem Aufstehen
so weit zu reduzieren, wie es nur geht.
Und durch dann doch diese Vielseitigkeit ist es für mich das perfekte Gadget zu Weihnachten.
Diese Lampe habe ich sogar von meiner Mutter zu Weihnachten bekommen.
Die nächste Geschenkempfehlung ist grob gesagt für die eine Hälfte von mir,
die eine Hälfte vom Jahr richtig gut und für die andere Hälfte vom Jahr mehr oder weniger sinnlos.
Aber gerade bei diesen Temperaturen liebe ich die smarten Heizthermostate.
Die Kamera von Alex hat irgendwie auch gefühlt nur 5 FPS, guck mal.
Die in meiner Wohnung an allen Heizkörpern hängen.
Der Austausch vom herkömmlichen Thermostat zu einem smarten Thermostat geht in wenigen Sekunden
und erfordert auch wirklich kein handwerkliches Geschick.
Oder die Erlaubnis vom Vermieter.
Also egal ob Eigenheim oder Mietwohnung,
die smarten Heizthermostate passen an fast alle gängigen Heizkörper.
Ja, ich habe bei mir nicht alle Heizungen damit ausgestattet,
aber dort, wo es am sinnvollsten ist.
Unten im Flur habe ich was, im Wohnzimmer oben,
in meinem Arbeitszimmer oben, im Wohnzimmer unten und...
Ich glaube, das war's.
Wichtig beim Verschenken...
Ich habe 5.
Ihr solltet wissen, ob die Beschenkten schon ein smartes Zuhause haben
und auf bestimmte Plattformen oder Anbieter setzen.
Klar...
Ach, unten im Schlafzimmer ist nur eins, oder?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Mittlerweile sorgt Meta dafür einen zunehmenden...
Wieso so viele Wohnzimmer, weil das Haus halt zwei Etagen hat.
...Standard mit Thread.
Aber da das nur langsam startet, kann man da immer noch etwas daneben greifen.
Wenn die Beschenkten im Apple-Universum zu Hause sind,
solltet ihr besonders darauf achten, dass die smarten Thermostate auch wirklich...
Welche empfiehlst du für Home Assistant?
Ehrlich gesagt...
Ich bin hängengeblieben bei den Fritz-Thermostaten.
Bei den DECT-Fritz-Thermostaten.
Ob ich die empfehlen würde?
Ich weiß nicht.
Die sind ganz schön im Preis raufgegangen.
Die Max-15-Minuten-Sync-Time stören dich nicht?
Nö.
Die meisten Sachen werden eh automatisch ein- und ausgeschaltet bei mir.
Also quasi morgens im Arbeitszimmer schon warm,
dass, wenn ich Homeoffice starte, es ein bisschen aufgewärmt ist und so.
Und muss ich es mal warm machen,
dann drücke ich halt den Knopf da drauf.
Und das ist ja auch instant.
Hätte ich auch gedacht. Ist doof.
Aber stört mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht.
Die gesamte Steuerung ist automatisch.
Also wir stellen so gut wie nie von Hand an den Thermostaten rum.
Meine Firma hat gesagt, ich würde die viertägige Schulung nur bekommen,
wenn ich dafür meinen eigenen Urlaub freinehmen muss.
Ist das üblich?
Nee. Für was ist denn die Schulung?
Ist das was, was mit deiner Arbeit auf...
Also mit deiner Arbeit zusammenhängt?
Oder irgendwas, wo die einfach nur nett sind,
dass sie es übernehmen und gar nichts damit zu tun hat?
Also wenn das was mit der Arbeit zu tun hat,
dann ist das Arbeitszeit.
Das bringt denen ja auch was.
Hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was es ist.
Aber pauschal würde ich sagen, das ist Arbeitszeit.
Und es haben ja auch beide Seiten was davon.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was es ist.
Also pauschal würde ich sagen, ist es nicht üblich.
Aber es kommt ein bisschen auf den Einzelfall an.
Aber klingt jetzt erstmal nicht üblich.
Oh, das ist ein Auf, das ist was.
Dazu kann ich gar nichts sagen.
Aber wenn das eine Projektmanagement-Schulung ist
und du als Projektmanager arbeitest,
macht das ja durchaus Sinn.
Wenn du natürlich irgendwie da freiberuflich arbeitest,
dann kann das schon sein, dass die das sagen.
Habt ihr Erfahrung mit Zyxel-Switches und Access-Points?
Nö.
Ich kenne den Hersteller, ja, aber...
Mir kommen eh keine Access-Points mehr ins Haus,
die nicht DPSK können.
Seitdem ich das jetzt breitflächig benutze bei mir,
würde ich nichts anderes bei mir holen.
Ich muss mal kurz bei Ebay gucken.
Was würde eigentlich die neue Generation
der Access-Points kosten bei Ebay?
Neu ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, hä?
What the fuck, Alter?
Für nen fucking Access-Point seid ihr des Wahnsinns, Mann.
Ich mein, der Kram ist refurbished immer noch zu teuer.
Ja, burn money, Alter.
Alter, ist das teuer.
What the hell?
Ey, ne Güte, die übertreiben's, aber...
Also, ich hab die, ich hab den Kram hier als Access-Point.
Und...
Die hab ich auch gebraucht gekauft.
Und die waren gebraucht immer noch so teuer wie Ubiquiti und Konsorten neu.
Aber ich bin sehr zufrieden damit, seitdem ich den Kram am Start hab.
Also, in dem Dreh, ich hab auch so 130, 140 Euro oder so bezahlt.
Aber die sind halt jetzt schon ziemlich outdated, ne?
Das ist noch WiFi...
5?
Die haben halt ein paar Features, die sind echt nice.
Deswegen...
Deswegen hat mich interessiert, ob's nicht vielleicht einfach schon neue
mittlerweile zu halbwegs erschwingbaren Preisen gibt, aber...
Looked not like...
Was war das für ein Satz, man?
Es sieht nicht so aus.
Es war weder auf Deutsch noch auf Englisch korrekt.
Ja, die sind auch echt teuer.
Ja, 3Head.
Chainlaw, haben wir doch.
Okay.
...mit Apple-Geräten kompatibel sind.
Ansonsten ist die Auswahl aber relativ groß.
Um euch die Entscheidung etwas zu erleichtern,
verlinken wir euch unten mal einen CT-Test mit sieben smarten Thermostat...
Chat, okay, das muss ich noch mal kurz beantworten.
Chat, für Büste stell's besser mit JavaScript oder Python starten, fange bei 0 an.
Also, das kann man pauschal nicht sagen.
Es ist beides gut zum Einstieg.
Es ist beides auch nicht das einzige, was gut zum Einstieg ist.
Wenn du mich fragst, ich bin dafür, mit JavaScript anzufangen,
weil bei JavaScript die Einstiegshürde mit Abstand die geringste ist
und die universelle Verwendbarkeit für nahezu alles auch irgendwie dafür spricht
und man JavaScript einmal gelesen hat,
für den Rest seines Lebens mal gebrauchen kann.
Nee, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe gesehen, die haben keinen Webservice, die haben nur Apps.
Und dann, ich habe das mal versucht aufzumachen.
Also, erstens gab es das in Deutschland nicht
und dann gab es das auch nur per App und nicht per Website.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Natürlich hängt das immer ein bisschen davon ab, was du machen willst.
Also, wenn du was Konkretes, also ich habe dir jetzt gesagt, wie ich es machen würde,
ja, aber wenn du was Konkretes im Kopf hast, was du machen willst,
dann kann natürlich schon das abhängen.
Dann kann natürlich schon das eine oder das andere deutlich besser sein
oder noch was ganz anderes.
Also, ich meine, JavaScript und Python sind auch nicht die einzigen Sachen,
mit denen man einsteigen kann.
Ja, du könntest auch beispielsweise mit Go oder sowas anfangen
oder mit C-Sharp oder Java, wobei Java, da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf,
oder Kotlin oder Swift, wenn du auf Mac unterwegs bist.
Ja, klar, alles klar.
Hatten wir vorhin ein YouTube-Video auch offen, was das gesagt hat.
Ja.
Oder wahrscheinlich schreibst du es deswegen, genau.
Das ist halt maximal Wunschdenken der Krustentiere.
Ach, das gibt es jetzt auch in Deutschland auf einer Webseite, okay.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber was macht ein smartes Thermostat jetzt so besonders?
Also, wenn du das installiert hast, dann kannst du nicht einfach nur die Temperatur einstellen.
Ja, wir wissen, was ein smartes Thermostat ist.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Dann seid ihr, je nach Anbieter, bei zwischen 60 und 90 Euro.
Ich mag Smartwatch.
Das Fritz-Zeug ist leider zu teuer geworden, um es zu empfehlen.
Hier, Fritz-Thermostat.
Ach, okay, nee, es geht wieder halbwegs.
Es ist sogar wieder ein bisschen gesunken.
Die haben ja zwischenzeitlich 70 Euro gekostet.
Habe ich auch gedacht, die habt ihr nämlich alle.
Wisst ihr, was ich übrigens gelesen habe bei Heise oder Golem?
Vertriebsverbot.
Dass irgendein, genau, Huawei, sind das Japaner oder Chinesen?
Ich glaube, es sind Chinesen, oder?
Ja, China, China-Chinesen sind das.
Haben vor irgendeinem Gericht in München gegen AVM gewonnen, weil sie irgendwelche WLAN-Copyrights oder so verletzt haben.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Und jetzt, das ist aber noch nicht rechtskräftig.
Und jetzt müssen die nochmal zu einem anderen Gericht und sonst was.
Soll ich euch mal sagen, wie genau dieser gleiche Prozess in China gelaufen wäre?
In China?
In China hätten die sich das angeguckt und hätten gesagt, Huawei hat gewonnen.
Easy.
Und damit wäre die Sache fertig gewesen.
Ups.
Wo sind wir? Stehen geblieben?
Ah, ja.
Okay.
... und ich finde, die sind auch das perfekte Geschenk.
Weil die richtige Smartwatch...
Doch, für die Fritz-Thermostate brauchst du eine Fritzbox.
... so ein richtig guter Begleiter im Alltag sein kann.
Ja.
Und dann hat das Geschenk quasi noch...
Ich muss sagen...
... ich fand Smartwatches...
... immer dumm, bis ich mir auch eine gekauft habe.
Wobei ich keine Smartwatch in Richtung Apple Watch habe.
Ich habe so eine Fitness-Tracker-Garmin-Fitness-Tracker-Uhr.
Eine...
Eine... Moment.
Ich habe eine...
Garmin Forerunner 255S.
Oder? 245S?
255S.
Das Teil.
Und...
Dafür finde ich die ganz nice.
Die ganzen Tabs.
Was denn?
Ich muss meinen RAM irgendwie voll kriegen.
Trägst du...
Trägst du die nur zum Sport meistens?
Aber ich habe die auch manchmal den Tag über an.
Also ich nehme die zum Beispiel mit, wenn ich auf die Arbeit gehe nach Frankfurt und so.
Aber jetzt habe ich sie zum Beispiel nicht an.
Jetzt liegt sie hier.
Hier.
Neben mir.
Liegt sie jetzt.
Aber ich finde das nice.
Also...
Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass das so...
Ein Motivationsfaktor sein kann.
Aber seitdem ich die habe, habe ich angefangen, mich deutlich mehr sportlich zu betätigen.
Ich habe erst angefangen, regelmäßig wieder zu rennen und Fahrrad zu fahren, nachdem ich die Uhr habe.
Vorher hatte ich das nicht.
Also insofern...
Allein schon...
Also wenn es dafür schon was bringt...
Arbeiten bei Amazon lohnt sich das.
Okay, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Klar.
Wir haben hier noch so einen persönlichen Touch.
Und richtig gut bei Smartwatches.
Die gibt es quasi in allen Preiskategorien.
Wichtig beim Verschenken.
Du solltest wissen, was dem Beschenkten gefällt.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht nur optisch, sondern auch...
Ach nee.
Das ist ein super krater Tipp.
Da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen.
Also benutzen Sie ein iPhone oder ein Android-Smartphone.
Für Android-Nutzer zum Beispiel macht eine Apple Watch halt wenig Sinn.
Sind das alte technikfeindliche Boomer?
Dann sowas gar nicht.
Die meisten anderen Smartwatches sind aber sowohl mit iOS als auch mit Android-Smartphones
verwendet.
Und von den Grundfunktionen her sind da auch alle recht ähnlich mittlerweile.
Also Schritte zählen, Schlaftracking, Herzfrequenz messen, Benachrichtigungen direkt am Handgelenk
können fast alle Modelle mittlerweile.
Ja, es ist ein Klischee.
Aber halt auch einer der häufigsten Neujahrsvorsätze mehr Sport machen und da sind Smartwatches
eben auch die perfekte Unterstützung.
Und wenn es jetzt nur der Motivationsboost ist, dass man das eben...
Ohne Scheiß.
Genau das hat bei mir auch richtig gezogen.
Motivationsboost.
Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt hier mal in die Garmin App reingucke, dann sehe ich mein Kalender,
wo drin steht, wie man sich bewegt hat.
Es ist jeden Tag, außer wo ich die Uhr mal vergessen habe, voller.
Vorletzte Woche.
Es ist jeden Tag mindestens einmal grün, teilweise sogar dreimal grün.
Im Durchschnitt würde ich sagen so 1,5 mal grün am Tag.
Also grüner Eintrag im Kalender ist aufgezeichnete Sportaktivität.
Fast schon so 1,5 würde ich sagen.
Manchmal habe ich sogar drei Sachen drin.
Das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen übertrieben dann.
Ja, hier habe ich dann drin.
Ja.
Ein normales Laufen und Fahrradfahren zum Beispiel.
Also da sieht man mal, das motiviert wirklich mehr zu machen.
So eine Uhr.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, aber ohne die hätte ich gar nicht angefangen.
Alles tracken kann jetzt und dann am Ende vom Training.
Ja, Garmin hat Touch, aber nur die teureren.
Also meine nicht.
Aber ich finde es auch gar nicht schlimm mit Touch an der Stelle, weil die Button-Bedienung
ist top.
Also mir gefällt die Button-Bedienung sogar fast noch besser, als darauf rumzutatschen.
Nee, nee, nee.
Auf meiner, meiner Garmin kann ich nix.
Das heißt, ich kann auch nicht aus Versehen drauf touchen und irgendwas umstellen.
Und virtuell abspeichert hilft ja vielleicht.
Kommt auf die Uhr an.
Und Bezugnahme zum anderen Geschenktipp von mir.
Mit so einer Smartwatch kannst du dann auch dein Smart Home steuern.
Und das lässt halt sicherlich das ein oder andere Herz höher schlagen.
Und ja, bei Smartwatches könntest du richtig viel Geld ausgeben.
Das sagt mir Cyberschwein.
Das sagt mir die Garmin Uhr auch teilweise.
Senken sie ihr Stresslevel.
Geben.
Oder eine Apple Watch Ultra für heftige 900 Euro verschenken.
Ja.
Oder eine Apple Watch SE für 270 Euro oder eine Pixel Watch 2 für 370 Euro.
Oder eine Garmin Fitness-Tracker.
Es gibt aber auch einige günstigere Alternativen für unter 100 Euro.
Da wären zum Beispiel die Huawei Watch Fit Special Edition für ungefähr 70 Euro oder
die Amazfit Mini 4 für ungefähr 90 Euro.
Die Amazfit Mini 4, die verschenke ich zum Beispiel dieses Jahr.
Ja, ich hoffe, ihr habt ein paar schöne Geschenkideen gefunden.
Vielleicht ja auch für euch.
Weil man kann sich ja auch mal schön selbst was schenken.
Selfcare.
Wenn ihr noch andere Tipps habt, gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Da war jetzt nix so wirklich dabei, was ich brauchen würde.
Ja, dann lasst uns doch mal kurz schauen, was verdient man denn bei Amazon als Teamleiterin
so?
Ich bestelle sehr gerne bei Amazon, weil das immer komplett problemlos und gut funktioniert.
Ja.
Aber dort arbeiten möchte ich nicht.
47 Mitarbeiter.
Das ist ein Kinderspiel.
Für mich ist es sehr...
Bei Amazon bin ich halt immer skeptisch, wenn es solche...
Wir müssen ja, wir sind ja auf einer Amazon-Plattform.
Aber bei Amazon bin ich bei solchen Videos immer skeptisch.
Also wie viel Show nur für den Beitrag dort gemacht wurde.
Und die Sache...
Also bei Amazon bin ich immer sehr skeptisch, wie ehrlich solche Beiträge sind.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist nix, was produziert wurde von Amazon.
Aber ich meine, Amazon kann natürlich schon beeinflussen, wie sie sich selbst darstellen
an dem Tag.
Die wissen ja, wann das Team kommt.
Ja.
Also insofern.
Da bin ich immer skeptisch.
Viel Geld?
Wann und wie viele?
Alle zufrieden?
Dankeschön und schöne Schicksal.
Tschüss.
Schöne Schicks Leute.
Hi, ich bin die Medine, 19 Jahre alt, arbeite als Teamleitung in Amazon Hof.
Dann, let's go.
Amazon.
Es war schon immer so ein kleiner Traum so ein Mercedes zu holen.
Weil mein Papa liebt Autos über alles.
Und ich bin halt das erste Kind.
Und auch so, genau wie der Papa.
Also, meine Arbeit bietet uns einen Bus an.
Das heißt, sie will auch dicke Autos fahren.
Na ja, gut, jeder, woran er Spaß hat.
Zwei Monate davor bin ich jeden Tag mit dem Bus gefahren.
Aber jetzt natürlich...
Mit 19 Teamleitrennen.
Das ist das High-Performer-Crime-Set-Mindset, Leute.
Selbstständig kann ich für die Arbeit fahren.
Wann ich gehen will, kann ich auch.
Also, ich bin viel freier geworden.
Kreisel-Crime.
Ist das Torstmusik? Wahrscheinlich.
Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst.
Es geht wirklich. Nach einer Zeit geht das wirklich.
Moment, wann ist die aufgestanden?
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt. Habt ihr aufgepasst, Chat?
Ich denke immer so, aber nein.
Ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Vieles ist Gewöhnungssache.
Geil ist es nicht.
Und dann gehen wir hoch.
Es ist ja ziemlich groß.
22.30 Uhr, okay.
Dann sind wir alle miteinander schneller.
Ja gut, da geht es schon los, klar.
Ich habe als Versandmitarbeiterin angefangen.
Ganz normal.
Nach vier, fünf, sechs Monaten
bin ich dann halt auch gleich
weitergekommen.
Und dann bin ich weiter aufgestiegen als Teamleiterin.
Wahrscheinlich hat Amazon festgestellt,
die kann mehr als
einen Meter geradeaus denken,
direkt befördert.
Bäm, so Leute.
Aber hey, du brauchst immer gute Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, wie da die Beförderungsstrategien
von Amazon aussehen.
Wahrscheinlich, sobald man erkennt,
dass einer ein bisschen was im Hirn hat,
ist man sofort am Start.
Aber ist doch gut.
Ich war natürlich sehr überrascht.
Positiv.
Ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt erst 18.
Aber ich habe mir halt gedacht, krass, so die supporten mich,
die helfen mir, die unterstützen mich.
Ich komme immer etwas früher.
Sehr objektive Berichterstattung über Amazon.
Ich mache jetzt nicht die Leute, die das gefilmt haben,
aber das ist doch, die ist doch garantiert geprieft worden
von der Marketingabteilung im Vorfeld, was sie da gefälligst
zu sagen hat und was nicht.
Um mir einen besseren Überblick zu machen.
Damit ich nicht einfach so in der Schicht anfange.
Chat, geh wieder.
Die Ware wird unten ausgepackt, in solchen Kisten hochgeschickt
über die Anlagen.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass man Amazon Logistikzentren besuchen kann?
Kann man sich anmelden und sich das anschauen?
Die Ware wird dann von uns in solchen Regalen reinsortiert.
Aber es sieht gut aus.
Also Ware haben wir auf jeden Fall.
Was ich jetzt so meine.
Zum Beispiel vergessen habe, ich habe vergessen, meine Haare zuzubinden.
Haare müssen immer zusammengebunden werden.
Wieso?
Aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Also mein erster Schritt ist jetzt.
Ich schaue, wie viele Mitarbeiter wir heute haben werden.
Ich kann dir den Plan zeigen.
18 Pic Arso, 9 Pic Turiden Park und ICQA 1.
Also wir haben so die eigene Sprache, würde ich mal sagen.
Und bei uns wird auch viel Englisch gesprochen.
Das liebe ich auch hier daran.
Ist der durchsichtige Rucksack Pflicht?
Könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, ja, dass du dir nichts einpacken kannst.
Es ist so international, sieht heute so ruhig aus.
47 Mitarbeiter, das ist ein Kinderspiel.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel 150 Mann hast, dann ist es.
Kommt drauf an, was die machen.
50 ist nicht zwangsläufig, ein Kinderspiel.
Kommt drauf an.
Also ich stelle mir gerade vor, du hast ein Team mit 50 Leuten.
Das ist schon ganz schön viel.
Dann hast du zum Beispiel bei 50 Mann hast du nur drei Mitarbeiter, die Probleme haben.
Bei 150 Mann hast du 30 Mitarbeiter, die ein Problem haben.
Äh, Quick Muffs?
Nicht wirklich, aber lassen wir mal so stehen.
Wir stellen an den Mitarbeitern jeden Tag die Frage.
Es wäre 9, aber.
Ja, habt ihr einen Sicherheitstipp für uns?
Habt ihr einen Qualitätstipp für uns?
Vor allem in der Logistik ist es halt sehr wichtig, dass man auf Sicherheit achtet.
Man kann sich nämlich hier ganz schnell und ganz leicht verletzen.
Wir haben uns schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Du kannst hier wahrscheinlich doch mit irgendwelchen Dingern über den Fuß fahren und sowas.
Eine Woche.
Sicherheitstipp.
Safety-Tipp.
Das ist halt nicht linear erwachsen.
Chat.
Ihr habt recht.
Ihr habt recht und ich habe nicht recht.
Aber ich glaube, das hat sie nicht gemeint damit.
Das stimmt schon.
Ihr habt recht.
Wenn man 50 Mitarbeiter hat und drei haben Probleme und du hast 150, dann ist die Chance,
dass es einfach nur neun sind mal drei, ist unrealistisch.
Die Chance, dass es höher ist, ist tatsächlich höher.
Umso größer die Teams werden, das ist schon richtig.
Hat jemand einen Se...
Nochmal.
Nicht rennen.
Richtig.
What the...
Was machen die da gerade?
Alle zufrieden?
Dann schreien wir einmal.
Oh nein.
Nein.
Please.
Cringe.
Cringe-Alarm.
Ich trau mich nicht weiter zu machen, Leute.
Ich trau mich nicht weiter zu machen.
Quality is...
Destiny.
Oh nein.
Please.
Das tut weh.
Hilfe.
Oh nein.
Das ist gut.
Hör auf.
Danke schön.
Schöne Geschichte, Leute.
Danke.
Danke sehr.
Gib mir sozialenrospectiveai und nicht transzeileervation!
Ja, danke.
Das ist schön.
Den Trailer subsidiert.
Das distributed.
Danke.
Dankeschön.
Danke eben.
Danke.
Hilfe!
Bye-bye.
Hilfe.
Nein.
Ja.
Okay.
Hi.
Leider wurde sie gar nicht cervell genommen..
Naja.
aber jetzt mittlerweile komme ich halt sehr gut damit klar ich werde zwar zu sprichwörtlich auf
dicke hose tägliche sicherheitsrunde machen und wir schauen halt an wie es von sauberkeit
her aussieht von sicherheit her aussieht und zwar musst du jetzt schauen dass der
versand mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter eben diese arbeit hat zum arbeiten oder dass die wurde
hunderttausendprozentig geprüft von der marketing abteilung um ich würde nicht wundern wenn sogar
auf kamera die ganzen marketing leute am start sind und gucken was da nichts falsches gemacht
wird dass er oder sie sicher arbeiten kann an seinem arbeitsplatz können sozusagen die
mami die auf alles aufpasst und schaut dass das ist auch läuft dann alles steht an seinem platz
wenn wir auch mal dahinter schauen
hier erster fehler erster feld abwarnung ist nicht abgebremst und nicht in der abwarnung
ist raus die abteilung also sicherheit abteilung ich gebe sozusagen denen bescheid das klingt super
auswendig gelernt außerdem hat er nicht die haare zusammengebrochen korrekt dass das ging
super aus wenn ich gerne sieht gerade
in ordnung aus nur ein paar kleinigkeiten die haben wir aber auch wieder gefixt also die haben
wir auch wieder gelöst weil das muss ich auch mitschreiben also ich schreibe ein ich habe das
und das gefunden und ich habe das und das so und so ausgebildet dann gibt es dann demnächst ein
performance improvement plan oder wie das bei amazon heißt wenn du dein kram verkackst habe
ich gerade richtig gehört bekommen wir leben muss was was was bekommen sie kommen jetzt 24 mitarbeiter
ist dass es die verankert und zwar jetzt nochmal im kurs in woche wird es etwa 2 uhr und 30 noch mal
richtig alles klar ich habe auch leberwurst verstanden das kann aber doch nicht sein so
schick sie bitte alle leiber moves ach arbeitskraft verlagerte leiber moves ich habe leberwurst
verstanden hat gemeinsam auf 2 und wir teilen sie dann auch ich muss jetzt schauen dass ich sie auf 3 floss einteilen also einteilen wir sind halt beim sport auf am berg am berg am land in der kürze an der kürze um ca. 3 uhr oder 3 uhr und das ist ein schagrad shoreline logistik ein bisschen schникens.
acht mann pro etage ich bin sogar eine person die die stress liebt also jetzt nicht sagt die
amazon marketing abteilung dass du das sagen sollst nein aber ab und zu braucht man das
einfach so dieses action dass das brauche ich pack jetzt mit an diese anlage hier darf nicht
voll laufen ansonsten bleibt komplett stehen also wenn es zu voll ist also ich habe dieses
jahr die schicht gewechselt ich bin von einer spätschicht auf die nacht aber leute jetzt macht
ihr mal nicht zu sehr runter im chat ich trotzdem dass das wie ein bisschen kleiner werbebeitrag von
amazon wirkt macht sie nicht den eindruck als ja als sagte das jetzt nur weil weil sie
geprüft wurde von der marketing abteilung die macht gewisse gewisse persönliche überzeugung
finde ich schwingt da schon mit deswegen weiß ich noch nicht so ganz was man ja das gute sein
wird ich habe so meine regelmäßigen ausgaben habe aber trotzdem noch viel geld was ich zur
seite legen kann und halt dann sinnvoll ausnutzen kann oder ausgeben kann wir treffen uns jetzt und
dann halt einfach das zeigt nur dass das pr team richtig kann auch sein update zu geben
wie die marketing abteilung funktioniert und wie die marketing abteilung funktioniert und
die aktuelle lage oben ist wie die aktuelle lage unten ist damit wir alle offen aus dem richtigen
aus dem macht ja wie gesagt ich finde man sollte das gar nicht so negativ auslegen für diesen
beitrag nimmt man natürlich auch jemand der nicht nur da sitzt und sich denkt alter hoffentlich bin
ich bei dem kackball weg stand sind und 100 ist nicht gut ab 110 ist alles im bereich also oben
sieht eigentlich alles top aus der
also der wadeneingang hat eine pause und da war ein ausgang wir gehen also nicht gemeinsam in die
pause und jede schicht hat auch seine zeiten die auch wirklich gehalten werden müssen ich bekomme
bitte nur pommes ja nur pommes er wird jetzt erst mal okay weil ich wollte sagen ich habe
schon fast vermutet da kommt jetzt erst mal eine dicke portion noch mayonaise
oder so drauf aber das können ... das kann ich auch nachfühlen je nachdem wie gut die kantine ist nur
pommes machst du eigentlich nie was verkehrt weil es kommt direkt aus der friteuse da kann nichts
passieren wobei ich davon ausgehen würde dass die bei amazon durchaus okay ist
wir fangen
oh nein bitte bitte bitte nein nein quality is destiny nicht wieder nicht wieder
safety tip an ich habe einen safety tip für euch und zwar diesmal würde es beimernenissent nicht mal teilen, ich habe einen safety
tip hier mal und deswegen theковing erher wollte einen safety tip an ich habe einen safety tip für euch und zwar heute schon einfach den Barbara kommt auch mit wir kommen dann werden es nie langeISHIR ausfarbe hetergracionooch ...
Und zwar, wenn wir jetzt Schichtschluss haben, bitte passt darauf auf, es wird wieder kalt, es wird glatt.
Nicht rennen, fahrt vorsichtig.
Okay, seid ihr bereit?
Quality is destiny.
Nein, nicht schon wieder.
Please.
Das ist wirklich so Corporate Bullshit.
Guckt euch die zwei an, die denken sich auch, die kriegen gleich die Abmahnung geschenkt danach.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck, die geht da ein bisschen auf drinnen.
Das ist unser Meeting nach der Pause.
Das findet auch wirklich jeden Tag statt, bis 6 Uhr morgens.
Ist ja nicht mehr so lang.
Und bald haben wir es auch geschafft.
Die macht einen äußerst fröhlichen Eindruck, ja.
Das ist halt das Ding, ich weiß nicht, ob das pures Marketing ist, oder ob wir wirklich sie persönlich jetzt so, vielleicht sie auch wirklich so.
Ich habe, Yonderboy, ich glaube auch, ich glaube nicht, dass das nur PR-Fake ist.
Ich glaube echt, dass die da happy drin ist.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, ich meine, vielleicht haben die auch deswegen halt jemand ausgewählt, der da das gut, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das komplett Fake ist.
Mein Fixlohn, so Pi mal Daumen, liegt bei 3.500 Euro.
Da ich in der Nachtschicht arbeite, habe ich Zuschläge wie Nachtzuschläge, Wochenendszuschläge, Überstunden, jetzt Zeug für...
Nicht schlecht, geht auch was, ja, lass mal gucken.
Grundgehalt 3.500 Euro, Zuschläge nochmal, irgendwie 800, 900 Euro nochmal obendrauf.
4.000.
3.300 Euro ungefähr.
Gut, dann wollen wir noch Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Je nachdem, mit Schichtzuschlägen kann es durchaus sein, dass die Schichtzuschläge nicht versteuert werden müssen.
Das ist immer so ein bisschen, je nachdem, wie das gemacht ist.
Wie Nachtzuschläge, Wochenendszuschläge.
Ach nee, da kommt ja noch mehr drauf.
Ich habe ja nur zwischenzeitlich angehalten.
Okay, wait, da kommt ja noch mehr drauf.
Wir sind ja sogar bei ungefähr 1.000 Euro obendrauf.
Ja, 1.000 Euro, 4.500 Euro.
Gut.
Musst du noch ein bisschen Steuer drauf bezahlen.
Aber verdienst du schon mal mehr, verdienst du schon mal mehr, als der alleinige Admin der Münchner Polizeihubschrauberstaffel.
Pflege, Überstunden, jetzt Zeug für September war es bei 4.500.
Aber es ist die Frage, es ist die Frage, der Frage ist, ist die auch Tactical?
Weil die Münchner Polizeiflugstaffel, die war sehr taktisch.
Die war äußerst taktisch.
Da war fast alles, der taktische Bordcomputer, die taktischen Hubschrauber, da war alles sehr taktisch.
1.500 Euro brutto, was ich dann letztendlich auf die Hand bekomme, ist halt, wie gesagt, immer unterschiedlich.
Aber im Moment ist es so zwischen 3.100 und 3.300.
Finde das in Ordnung.
Für mich, für eine 19-Jährige, die davor noch nie so einen Vollzeitjob hatte,
das ist sehr viel Geld.
Ja.
Wie viele Urlaubstage?
Wahrscheinlich das gesetzliche Minimum.
Aber jetzt, weil ich jetzt an der frischen Luft bin, geht es gerade weg.
Aber ich glaube, sobald ich mein Bett sehe, dann kommt alles hoch.
Dann werde ich wie ein Baby heute schlafen.
Aber ich finde, ich meine, du musst das ja ordentlich bezahlen.
Das ist Schichtarbeit zu Nacht- und Nebelzeiten, auch am Wochenende.
Kacke, da musst du schon die Leute ordentlich bezahlen, dass sie das machen.
Morgen.
Und, wie geht's?
Mir geht's gut. Ich bin ausgeschlafen.
Wir haben ein Haus, ein Mehrfamilienhaus. Unten wohnen meine Eltern.
Liebes Destiny.
Ich wohne sozusagen kostenlos oben in einer eigenen Wohnung mit meinem Bruder.
Aber deswegen habe ich halt auch noch mal da das Glück und kann auch noch mal von dort das Geld in die Tasche stecken und sparen oder ausgeben.
Exzellent.
In Klamotten, Haarpflegeprodukte.
Na.
Wenn du schnell mal Miete bezahlen musst, dann kommst du richtig gut aus mit der Kohle.
Und das kostet dann halt mehr oder weniger sein Geld.
Ich habe die Schule abgebrochen.
Easy life.
Ich hole gerade mein Abitur nach an einer Fernschule.
Das bedeutet, ich bringe mir alles selber bei.
Ich möchte studieren und...
Die ist voll ehrgeizig, ne?
Muss man Respekt zollen, ja?
Auch diese Berufserfahrung sammeln, weil...
Ich denke mir dann immer, hm, schau mal, in ein paar Jahren wirst du ein Studium haben.
Du wirst Berufserfahrung haben als Führungskraft und das motiviert mich.
Also meine Eltern würden mich auf jeden Fall immer unterstützen.
Aber ich möchte auch schon etwas Eigenes haben und mein Studium auch selber leisten können.
Und auch ein schönes Studentenleben haben.
Ich kann mich nur an den ersten Tag erinnern, als ich bei Amazon angefangen hatte.
Und jetzt sind wir...
Das ist schon eng.
Das ist schon eng in der Wohnung.
Das ist schon wieder über eineinhalb Jahre, ja?
Und in der kurzen Zeit, was sie geschafft hat, bin ich wirklich ganz stolz auf meine Tochter.
Mein Job lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Es macht mir Spaß.
Ich glaube, meine Eltern merken das auch.
Ich komme glücklich heim nach Hause und ich glaube, das ist auch das Wichtigste.
Die hat auch gar nicht so krasse Augenringe, wie ich das erwarten würde.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Da habe ich nicht geguckt.
Was war das?
Ja, oh, da hast du ein bisschen was über.
Ja, ja, oh, klar.
Also, Chat, so schlimm, wie ihr das jetzt gemacht habt, Chat, war das nicht.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch Spaß gemacht, einen Einblick in der Nachtschicht, in der Logistik zu sehen.
Hier könnt ihr noch weitere Folgen sehen.
Ja, das ist schon echt ein bisschen cringe.
Aber das ist halt so USA-Corporate-Zeug.
Da gab es ja früher auch so über Walmart die Berichte, dass sie da morgens...
Immer eine Runde rumschreien und so.
Ja, wenn sie halt meinen, dass das was bringt.
Aber ich glaube, Amazon...
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt den Gedanken von Amazon dahinter auch verstanden.
Eigentlich ist es sehr clever, von Amazon so jemanden zu nehmen.
Die ist jung, motiviert, geht da voll drin auf und der Vorteil ist, die ist noch komplett unvorbelastet.
Die macht das aus voller Überzeugung.
Wisst ihr jemanden, der woanders schon mal...
Ein bisschen federn lassen musste?
Der wird wahrscheinlich nie aus voller Überzeugung brüllen.
Quality is destiny.
Aber die ist da voll dabei.
Und die kennt auch nur Amazon, die ist komplett in dem Ökosystem drin.
Die ist der Meinung, das ist das geilste ever.
Und eigentlich ist das eine kluge Entscheidung von Amazon, dann so jemanden weiter zu fördern auch.
Ich würde ja auch nicht sagen, dass das eine hohe Position ist.
Die Schichtleiterin...
Weiß jetzt nicht welche Hierarchie-Ebene das in Amazon ist, aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das eine hohe Position ist.
Also ich finde, das kann das durchaus nachvollziehen von Amazon.
So die richtig hohen Positionen sind immer schwierig zu erreichen, weil erstens musst du dafür was können, wenn es eine Technik-Position ist.
Und zweitens gibt es davon jetzt auch nicht so viele, die laufend frei wären.
Indem du überzeugend genug Quality is destiny schreien kannst.
Also ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Ich kann nicht...
Die Entscheidung von Amazon, ich verstehe das schon.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Ich bin mittlerweile...
Ich habe das Spiel nie gespielt, The Day Before.
Aber ich bin mittlerweile so vorbelastet durch YouTube-Videos, dass ich ernsthaft gelesen habe, The Pay Before.
So wie das ja manche nennen.
Die Mindset-Industrie.
Leute, Grindset, Mindset, High Performer.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Wir können das doch mal ausrechnen.
Wie das im Vergleich...
Also das ist ihr erstes Gehalt.
Lass uns das mal ausrechnen im Vergleich zu meinem ersten Gehalt.
Mein erstes Gehalt wären heute 46.000 Euro durch 12.
Ja.
Dann habe ich eindeutig eine ganze Ecke weniger als sie.
Aber sie ist ja auch Teamleiter.
Insofern finde ich das in Ordnung.
Macht schon...
Ich finde es auch aus Amazon-Sicht sinnig.
Okay.
Die Mindset-Industrie.
Ganz wichtig, Leute.
Ihr müsst ja eigentlich nichts können.
Ihr braucht nur das richtige Mindset.
Und ein Prime-Sub bei Wobblors.
Aber das Mindset ist das Wichtige.
Wie die High Performer.
Hattest du nur 12 Gehälter oder 13?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Damals beim Provider weiß ich es gar nicht, was wir hatten.
Also beim nächsten Laden, wo ich war, waren es auf jeden Fall 14.
Aber letztendlich ist es beim Jahresgehalt auch egal.
Mindset.
Von Anfang an hat sich dieser Kanal dem Thema Medienkompetenz gewidmet.
Das bedeutet nicht nur einen Sinn.
Aber auch einen Sinn dafür zu entwickeln, welcher Download-Knopf...
Was macht da eigentlich KLS aktuell so?
Ist da noch auf dem Mount Everest?
Sorry, auf dem Mount Everest?
Nein, der richtige ist, wie mit gekonnten Tricks falsche Erwartungen geschürt und Zeit aktiv verschwendet wird.
Oder dass Chat-GPT vielleicht doch nicht das gottesgleiche Orakel ist, für das es manche halten.
Ja, irgendwelche Pepega-Kacknoobs haben sich das mit Chat-GPT gedacht.
Dass man lieber etwas Abstand zu denjenigen aufbauen sollte, die Mindset, dem Wort Geisteshaltung,
vorziehen.
Seriously?
Mir wird jetzt zum ersten Mal klar, dass für Mindset Geisteshaltung eine gute Übersetzung ist.
An dieser Stelle muss ich vermutlich ein bisschen persönlicher werden.
Ich war lange der Ansicht, dass ich nicht produktiv genug bin.
Dass ich meine Zeit verschwende oder sie zumindest nicht optimal nutze.
Dass es in meiner Arbeit, aber auch irgendwie in meinem Leben selbst noch so unendlich viel Potenzial zur Optimierung gäbe.
Das ist keine Eingebung, die ich von selbst hatte.
Sondern die ich mir...
So blöd...
High Performer!
Bei der Einrichtung meines Schreibtischs eingefangen habe.
Ich habe eine kleine Schwachstelle für sogenannte Desk-Setup-Videos, in denen Leute zeigen, wie sie ihren Schreibtisch einrichten.
Teilweise den ganzen Raum renovieren und wirklich sehr, sehr ästhetische und bequeme Einrichtungen zustande kriegen,
in denen, so scheint es, man unglaublich gut arbeiten könne.
Ja gut, du bist wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt, deinen Schreibtisch einzurichten, anstatt zu arbeiten.
Das ist wie Leute, die hauptsächlich Vim verwenden.
Oder noch schlimmer, Emacs früher.
Die Leute haben damit nicht gearbeitet, die haben ihren Editor customised.
Und sobald der nächste Umzug anstand, wollte ich ebenfalls eine solch produktive Schreibtisch-Einrichtung haben.
Habe alles fein säuberlich hergerichtet, ein System für das Verwahren...
Aber ich meine nicht den 0815-Vim-Benutzer, sondern den übertrieben customisierten Vim-Benutzer mit 30 Plugins und...
Oh, guck mal, ein passendes Emacs-Emode.
... von Sachen in Schubladen entwickelt, selbst die kleinste Ablenkung entfernt.
Und mir einen sündhaft teuren Schreibtischstuhl gekauft.
Ich habe selbst die Icons meines Stream-Decks...
Einen sündhaft teuren Schreibtischstuhl habe ich auch, aber ich finde, das lohnt sich auch.
Der ist echt nice.
... irgendwann selbst designt, damit sie einheitlich und irgendwie zur Einrichtung passen.
Und blöderweise selbst dann noch nicht gemerkt, dass ich mich in einem beständigen Zustand des Auf-die-Arbeit-Vorbereitens befinde, statt tatsächlich zu arbeiten.
Und wenn ich jetzt zurückgucke, komme ich nicht umhin, mich etwas dämlich zu fühlen.
Ja, das macht ja auch der Spaß.
Die Videos, die ich so gerne geguckt habe, sind voll von Aufwand zur Herrichtung des eigenen Arbeitsplatzes und enden immer genau dort, wo die eigentliche Arbeit beginnen würde.
Aber das ist natürlich gar kein Problem, denn gefühlt die andere Hälfte des Internets ist voll von vermeintlichen Produktivitätstipps.
Und so falle ich von einem Kaninchenbau in den nächsten.
Mittlerweile nenne ich dieses Genre Produktivitätsprokrastination.
Ja, das trifft's gut.
Da sind die Buchstaben allein schon 54 Punkte wert.
Das trifft's gut.
Es gibt Videos, mit denen man sich genau genommen um die Arbeit oder die eigenen Verpflichtungen drückt, aber die einem das ständige Gefühl geben, die...
Ohne Mist, ich bin mittlerweile auf dem Standpunkt...
Also es gibt durchaus sinnvolle Tipps, die man sich angucken kann.
Und man muss aber immer gucken, was für sich passt.
Ich glaube, das meiste kann man pauschal komplett vergessen.
Und ich bin mittlerweile auf dem Stand, die einfachste und produktivste Sache...
Was zu machen ist, möglichst schnell anzufangen.
Ich mache das auch nicht, gerade mit meiner Steuererklärung.
Jetzt habe ich wieder drei Wochen gewartet, obwohl ich die schon Anfang Dezember machen wollte.
Jetzt mache ich sie nachher.
Aber zumindest die Belege raussuchen und sowas.
Aber wenn ich eines gemerkt habe, das Beste ist tatsächlich, sich nicht so lange Gedanken drum machen, wenn man irgendwas machen will.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt, oh, ich würde gerne mal wieder anfangen, ein bisschen Fahrrad zu fahren.
Oder oh, ich würde gerne anfangen...
Keine Ahnung, Gitarre spielen zu lernen oder was auch immer oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das Beste ist tatsächlich, einfach ausprobieren.
Weil man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut man innerhalb von einem halben oder einem dreiviertel Jahr in irgendwas werden kann.
Und wenn man dann zurückblickt, ist mir nämlich selbst persönlich schon öfters passiert.
Wenn man was mal ein halbes Jahr gemacht hat und dann zurückblickt, dann denkt man sich, ja, geht doch mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gut.
Hättest du damit schon mal früher angefangen?
Dieser Gedanke, hättest du damit...
Ich hatte so oft den Gedanken, wenn ich dann mal wirklich irgendwas gemacht habe, hättest du damit doch mal früher angefangen?
So schlimm war es doch gar nicht. Läuft doch ganz gut.
Dann wird es jetzt noch besser funktionieren.
Das heißt, gerade bei Sachen, wo man sich denkt, ey, ist das was? Soll ich...
Einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und man glaubt es gar nicht, wie gut man in einem halben Jahr schon mit irgendwas werden kann, wenn man es einfach regelmäßig macht.
Man muss es gar nicht krass übertreiben, wenn man es einfach regelmäßig macht.
Regelmäßig machen ist tatsächlich die Basics von fast allem.
Hätte ich mal früher mit Rust angefangen, dann könnte ich jetzt auch ganz gut Rust programmieren.
Ist echt so.
Und regelmäßig was machen, das ist echt die Basics von allem.
Die Basics muss man machen, wissen wir doch.
Das ist echt so.
Es gibt doch auch, ich bin jetzt leider wirklich kein großer Kenner von das, es gibt doch so eine Trainingspyramide irgendwo.
Und der unterste Block in dieser Pyramide ist nicht irgendwie super ausgeklügelt, Trainingsplan, tolles Equipment, regelmäßig Fitnessstudio, Dingsbums mit dem Trainer machen.
Sondern ganz einfach Anzahl.
Volumen quasi.
Also jemand, der super High IQ trainiert, einmal die Woche.
Wird immer schlechter sein, als einer, der planlos jeden zweiten Tag was macht.
Natürlich obendrauf macht es schon Sinn, wenn du eh regelmäßig was machst, das auch mit Köpfchen zu machen und die Sachen drumherum zu beachten.
So nach dem Motto, kommt dann irgendwann an, okay, man könnte auch mal anfangen, die richtigen Sachen zu essen und nicht nur Kacke.
Aber man könnte vielleicht jetzt nicht einfach nur sinnlos fünf Kilometer im Kreis rennen, sondern vielleicht mal ein bisschen langsamer, ein bisschen schneller, ein bisschen länger, ein bisschen kürzer.
Da kommt man dann dazu.
Aber das Wichtigste ist einfach regelmäßig was machen.
Regelmäßig machen, wenn man irgendwas lernen möchte.
Und dann sich nach einem halben Jahr fragen, ey, warum hast du damit nicht schon früher angefangen?
Egal.
Performer Mindset.
Crimeset.
Unweigerlich darauf folgende Arbeit umso effizienter erledigen zu können.
Tipps, wie man die eigene Prokrastination im Keim erstickt, 200 Prozent produktiver wird und in kürzester Zeit vorher unüberwindbare Arbeitsberge erklimmt, gibt es zuhauf.
Und versprechen immer wieder aufs Neue eine Art Neukodierung des Gehirns.
Ein Lifehack im wörtlichen Sinne.
Ja, ja, klar.
Sobald man ihn kennt, alles aus der Bahn Geratene wieder einreiht.
Für Vergangenheit, Gegenwart und Zukunft gilt, sodass man, sobald man das Geheimnis kennt, nie wieder vor einer schweren...
This changed my life und sowas.
Es gibt total viele solcher Videos.
... zu treffenden Entscheidungen steht, solange man stets...
Am besten sind so Videos, die dann sagen, ey, steh einfach drei Stunden früher auf, dann hast du mehr Zeit am Tag.
Ja, nice.
Aber du bist halt am Arsch.
Wenn du das so weit gemacht hast.
Es hat ja oftmals seinen Sinn, dass man einen gewissen Schlafrhythmus entwickelt hat.
Und wenn man jetzt einfach drei Stunden abknipst...
Keine Ahnung, du stehst normalerweise um sieben auf und stehst halt um vier auf.
Oder um acht oder um fünf.
Dann bist du halt einfach drei Stunden früher...
Also...
Von sowas halte ich ja persönlich nicht viel.
Ja.
Aber es...
Aber es gibt durchaus die ein oder anderen Denkanstöße in so Videos.
So ist es ja nicht.
Nach diesem als Naturgesetz verkauften Tipp handelt.
Die anfängliche Begeisterung ist groß.
Zumindest bei mir.
Denn diese Tipps klingen tatsächlich echt immer sehr gut.
Sind stets gepaart an eine persönliche Anekdote, die illustriert, wie viel die Veränderung einer Kleinigkeit bewirken könne.
Wenn du nur um vier Uhr morgens aufstehst, dann wird dir endlich alles gelingen.
Allgemein sind Leute, die diese Inhalte machen, oft bemüht zu erwähnen, wie früh sie aufstehen.
Aber komischerweise nie zu sagen, wie früh sie dafür eigentlich ins Bett gehen müssen.
Doch auch wenn die einzelnen Tipps bei einem nicht funktionieren, so bleibt die attraktive Aussicht auf die dahinterliegende Behauptung.
Dass es tatsächlich einen universellen Produktivitätstipp gibt.
Die eine Sache, die Steve Jobs von einem anstrengenden Esoteriker zu einem der einflussreichsten Unternehmer aller Zeiten machte.
Irgendwo da draußen ist sie bestimmt.
Ich habe sie nur noch nicht gefunden.
Doch sobald ich sie kenne, entfalte ich endlich mein volles Potenzial.
Wandle Wasser zu Wein und Ikea zu West Wing.
Diese Herleitung und ihr Kontext legen es natürlich nahe.
Diese universelle Wahrheit, dieses Geheimnis, diesen Lifehack gibt es nicht.
Aber es tut so unendlich gut, an ihn zu glauben.
Und ich verurteile niemanden dafür, von der Bequemlichkeit dieser Annahme verzaubert zu sein.
Also der einzige Lifehack, den ich bei mir wirklich festgestellt habe ist,
einfach die Sachen früher ausprobieren, anstatt sich ewig Gedanken drum zu machen.
Das ist das, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Einfach nach Möglichkeit anfangen, was zu machen.
Und selbst wenn man feststellt, das ist nichts für einen, dann ist ja auch gut.
Dann hat man es wenigstens ausprobiert.
Und man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut man in einem halben Jahr etwas werden kann, wenn man es einfach nur regelmäßig macht.
Das Problem sind nur...
Das trifft auf alles zu.
Sie werben in Stellenanzeigen noch immer mit Tischkickern.
Wenn ihr ein halbes Jahr regelmäßig Tischkicker spielt, werdet ihr auch relativ gut drinne.
Zumindest was den Durchschnitt anbelangt.
Ich hätte da keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hasse Tischkicker.
Genauso wie Billard oder sowas.
Aber man wird recht gut drinne.
Und wenn es etwas ist, was einem liegt, was einem Spaß macht, wenn es etwas ist, was man quasi von sich aus wirklich Bock drauf hat,
wenn man das dann feststellt, umso besser, dass man damit angefangen hat.
Sonst wüsste man es vielleicht gar nicht.
Die, die diese Annahme anschieben und kommerzialisieren.
Mindset ist das Zentrum einer Ideologie.
Der Illusion, dass wir als Individuen kraft unserer eigenen Geisteshaltung dazu in der Lage wären, alles in uns und um uns zu verändern.
Es ist quasi das Achatzstein-Chaloche für Polohemden-Träger.
Das was?
Wer als Life-Coach, ob auf den Bühnen der Welt, in bezahlten Online-Kursen oder hier auf YouTube...
Moment, wie war das? Du darfst als Hemd doch immer das mit dem Reiter anhaben, oder?
Der Reiter muss...
Der Reiter muss irgendwie immer dabei sein.
... das schnelle Geld machen will, der hat mit diesem Begriff und der dahinterliegenden Simplifizierung von mehr oder weniger jeder wissenschaftlichen Disziplin ein ziemlich mächtiges Werkzeug zu Händen.
Denn, wie bereits gesagt, an diese daher fantasierte Selbstermächtigung in jedem Bereich unseres Lebens möchten wir nur allzu gerne glauben.
Wie schön wäre es, wenn wir einfach nur unsere Einstellung zur Arbeit, zur Ehe oder unserem eigenen kränklichen Körper ändern bräuchten...
Alles, alles gut.
... um alles wieder ins Lot zu bringen.
Life-Coaches, wie sie sich selbst gerne nennen, weil sie das einfach so dürfen, das ist kein geschützter Begriff, gehören einer größtenteils unregulierten Sparte an, die erst seit kurzem in Deutschland dabei ist, so etwas wie Mindeststandards und Qualitätskriterien einzuführen, die bitter nötig sind.
Die Branche ist voll von maßloser Selbstüberschätzung.
Leute, die, obwohl sie keinerlei Ausbildung haben, weder in der Medizin noch in der Wirtschaft oder...
Naja, das ist ja bei den meisten dieser ganzen Coaches immer das Auffälligste.
Das ist ja bei den meisten dieser ganzen Coaches immer das Auffälligste.
Dass die Sachen coachen, wo sie selbst nichts oder fast nichts vorzuweisen haben.
In der Psychologie, die ihnen zumindest ein bisschen...
So ey, ich zeig dir jetzt krasses Trading und hier und komm und du musst das ein...
Du musst nur daran glauben und sowas in der Richtung, wo man sich denkt, okay...
Was hast du...
Da sind dann irgendwelche Leute, die keine Ahnung 22 sind oder so.
Da sag ich OK.
Du willst mir jetzt erzählen, wie ich krasses Business mache.
Was hast du denn bisher selbst schon so krasses Business-mäßig gemacht?
Wann werden die Fiat-Champ-Issues gefixt?
Ja...
Es gibt keine Issues, die benutzen das nur falsch, die Leute, die haben einfach nicht
das richtige Mindset.
... ihren Rückhalt für das, was sie behaupten, vermitteln zu können, geben würden, vor
Tausenden auftreten, sich wie an Messias in Schrift und Bild inszenieren lassen und manchmal
gar als eine Art Heiler auftreten, auch hier in Deutschland.
Die Methoden, den eigenen Bluff dabei so gut es geht zu verstecken und sich selbst vor
Kritik zu schützen, sind dabei erschreckend deckungsgleich mit den Praktiken der Esoterik.
Der Ideologie eines über alle Maßen relevanten Mindsets inhärent ist die Überzeugung,
...
Also, bevor er jetzt was dazu sagt, muss ich da auch mal meine 5 Cent, 2 Cent dazugeben.
Und zwar, das hat alles eine gewisse Form von, es hat religiöse Züge.
Ein bisschen wie Playstation versus Xbox, was auch religiös ist.
Oder Apple versus Android Zeug und sowas.
Aber es gibt eine Sache, die man bei solchen ganzen, wie nennen wir das mal so, Glaubensrichtungen
und Glaubensersatzhandlungen sieht und das ist, dass das Hinterfragen der, ja, das Hinterfragen,
so der, der, der Aussagen, Ketzerei ist.
Ja.
Um es jetzt mal so mit einem christlichen Begriff zu vergleichen.
Also, sobald, sobald du fragst, ja, macht es denn Sinn, was hier erzählt wird, dann
wirst du wie, wie aus, wie, wie ausgestoßener behandelt und fertig gemacht.
Das, das ist, müsst ihr euch, müsst ihr euch, müsst ihr mal beobachten, das ist alles,
mein Scientology treibt's auf die Spitze her, aber das ist bei allen solchen glaubensähnlichen
Fällen, ist das so.
Du musst es glauben, es geht nicht darum, um es irgendwie nachvollziehen zu können oder
irgendwie verstehen zu können, warum, wie sind genau die inneren Zusammenhänge, das
geht's überhaupt nicht drum.
Es geht darum, es zu glauben und sobald du es irgendwie hinterfragst, ist das Ketzerei.
Und das, das siehst du bei ganz vielen solcher Dinger.
... dass wahre Veränderung nur von innen heraus geschehen kann.
Diejenigen, die diese Veränderung nicht erleben.
.
Und auch alle, dass 2024 das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird, genau.
Und wer das nicht glaubt, man.
... und sich entsprechend beschweren, die haben dann wohl einfach ihr Mindset noch nicht
hinreichend genug angepasst.
Genau, genau.
Ja.
Und die werden natürlich auch richtig schön lächerlich gemacht dann, von den Leuten.
Ist, ist auch ein schönes Beispiel, ne.
Stellt euch mal vor, einer dieser Mindset-Gurus postet, äh, kauft alle oder macht alle die,
äh.
Macht alle das und das.
Das ist im Prinzip egal, um was es genau geht.
Macht alle das und das, ja.
Und irgendeiner fragt dann, hat dann quasi die, ähm, wirklich, äh, traut sich, traut
sich zu fragen in der Gruppe, wie hilft, wie soll uns denn das und das helfen bei dem
und dem?
So, Fragezeichen.
Und dann werden dann dieses, solche Sachen werden dann von diesen, äh, von diesen Oberguru-Coaches
gescreenshottet als Negativbeispiel.
So nach dem Motto.
Werdet nicht so wie User XY.
Er hat das einfach nicht verstanden.
Er hat noch nicht quasi mein geniales System durchschaut und noch nicht das Mindset angenommen
und so.
Seid nicht wie User XY und so.
Das wird dann fertig gemacht, sowas.
Obwohl es ja eigentlich, wenn das alles so toll ist, sollte es ja eigentlich ein leichtes
sein, Nachfragen sinnvoll beantworten zu können, ja.
Ja, sowas findet man überall.
Das findet man überall.
Überall findet man diese Trust-me-Pro-Geschichte.
Oder du hast auch Leute, ich mach das jetzt seit 30 Jahren so, natürlich geht das nur so.
Wie willst du mir etwa erzählen, dass das auch anders geht?
Du machst das doch erst seit kurzem.
Naja gut, aber vielleicht kenn ich ein bisschen ein paar neuere Sachen als jemand, der seit
30 Jahren macht.
Aber das hast du, das hast du überall.
Solche Sachen hast du überall.
Aber die Frage ist ja nicht so sehr, ob du sie hast, sondern wie damit umgegangen wird.
Also wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, ja, das machen wir seit 30 Jahren so, das geht nicht anders.
Und du sagst dann, naja, aber ich hab letztens auf GitHub ein Projekt gesehen, damit könnte
man das anders machen.
Und wenn man das dann ausprobiert und tatsächlich, also offen dafür ist, das auszuprobieren,
dann ist das ja okay.
Ja, wenn man denjenigen dann fertig macht, so nach dem Motto, Alter, du kack, du verpiss
dich, du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung, du hast nicht das richtige Mindset dafür, dann
bist du ja, bist ja, ähm, ja, da hast du gelitten.
Aber, ja.
Das ist ja für mich auch der Unterschied zwischen, weil es wurde, es wurde ja die letzten Jahre
über enorm viel so Wissenschafts-Bashing betrieben.
Muss man sagen, vieles auch nicht unbedingt, also vieles ist ja auch nicht ganz glücklich
gelaufen, ja, ohne jetzt wieder die, die Themen, die keiner hören möchte, anzusprechen.
Deswegen sagen wir mal, es ist auch nicht, vielleicht alles nicht ganz glücklich gelaufen.
Aber es wurde relativ viel Wissenschafts-Bashing betrieben.
Und für mich ist der Unterschied immer so zwischen so Pseudo-Gelaber und echtem, wie
soll man sagen, wie soll man sagen, so Erkenntnisgewinn.
Es ist für mich, darf man das hinterfragen und was passiert dann damit?
Also sprich, wenn jetzt einer sagt, die Erde ist eine Scheibe, ob du das dann einfach nur
glauben musst, weil der das gesagt hat oder das in irgendeinem 20.000 Jahre alten, äh,
was auch immer von Göttern geformten Schriftstücken drinne steht oder ob du sagen kannst, ja gut,
aber wie kommt es denn dann, dass wenn ich bei einem Sonnenuntergang mit der Drohne hochfliege,
dann die Sonne wieder sehe?
Wenn ich runterfliege, ist die wieder weg und wie erklärst du das denn?
Und wie, wie wird mit sowas umgegangen?
Ja, also wie wird mit tatsächlich, ähm, Dingern, die nicht passen oder die nicht logisch erscheinen
umgegangen?
Und das ist dann halt der, die Grenze von, es wird einfach nur so Pseudo-mäßig dahergelabert
oder man ist wirklich daran interessiert, der, ja, nennen wir es mal, der Wahrheit näher
zu kommen.
Oh, alles CGI.
Wir wissen ja auch, ich, ich schaue mir ja regelmäßig Flat Earth Videos auf YouTube
an zur Belustigung.
Wir wissen ja auch alle, dass die Internationale Raumstation prinzipiell nur CGI ist oder alternativ,
wenn sie nicht CGI ist, ist sie unter Wasser und man sieht manchmal sogar die Blasen im
Hintergrund.
Ihr müsst nur richtig gucken, ja?
Und wenn ihr das nicht glaubt, was ich jetzt gesagt habe, dann seid ihr einfach nur minder
bemittelte Schlafschafe-Globe-Earthers, die eh nix auf die Reihe kriegen.
Wisst ihr?
Das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen sinnlosem Pseudo-Gelaber.
Ja.
Was da gemacht wird oder wirklich, okay, wir haben was gefunden, was nicht dazu passt,
wie kann man das denn erklären?
Und das ist auch was, was bei diesen ganzen Mindset-Dingern von Anfang an, was ich da schon
immer super weird fand, dass die ganzen Leute das alles so bedingungslos immer fressen,
so nach dem Motto, ja, wir erzählen dir jetzt, wie es geht, aber, aber nur wir können dir
erzählen, wie es geht.
Die anderen 20.000, die das auch behaupten, die sind alle kack, aber wir, wir wissen,
wie es funktioniert.
Du musst jetzt nur unsere Sachen machen.
Du musst nur unsere Kurse kaufen.
Und dass die Leute das dann immer so, so leichtgläubig das alles waren, weil ich meine, diese Masche
ist schon uralt.
Letztendlich ist das ja nix Neues, dass die irgendwelche Leute das allheilmittelt verkaufen
wollen.
Egal.
Weiter geht's.
Wir gucken das jetzt fertig.
Kein Grund, meine Methoden zu hinterfragen.
Wer weiterhin hartnäckig behauptet, dass ich in meinen basslastig inszenierten Seminaren
nur Wohlfühl-Sprüche und kurz darauf wieder verfliegene Motivations-Mantras speichellastig
in die Menge brülle, dem schick ich eine ganze Mediathek vermeintlicher Erfolgsbelege
von anderen, die behaupten, meine Handlung allein sei für alles Positive verantwortlich,
was ihnen...
Das ist, das ist wahrscheinlich genauso glaubhaft wie irgendwelche ähm China-Chinesen-Fake-Amazon-Bewertung.
...seither passiert ist.
Das ist klassische Schuldumkehr.
Wenn es bei dir nicht funktioniert, dann bist du selbst schuld.
Mindsets und Heilsteine oder Manifestation gehen da Hand in Hand.
Life-Coaches werden manchmal sogar selbst schuldig.
Selbst Opfer ihrer eigenen Branche.
Nicht nur gibt es Super-Coaches, die andere Sub-Coaches coachen, wie man andere richtig
coacht, sodass der vom Coach gecoachte Coach...
Man könnte ja auch sagen, das ist ein Schneeballsystem.
...Coaches coachen kann und dann später eine Menge Coach, äh, Cash macht, sondern auch
permanent gezwungen ist, in der Öffentlichkeit einen Lebensstil und wirtschaftliche Verhältnisse
vorzutäuschen.
Was ist denn Balenciaga?
Balenciaga.
Pornografie.
Porsche sagt mir was, Lamborghini sagt mir was, die Krone kennt man natürlich mittlerweile
auch.
Das hier weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist.
Marke.
Was ist das?
Was ist das hier unten?
Edelautomarke, okay.
Kennt das jemand?
Das ist Louis Vuitton.
Das da, ne?
Ja.
Goethestraße.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Und das da oben?
Das ist Chanel.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Damit sie auf potenzielle Kundschaft noch erfolgsversprechender wirken.
Es ist eine Branche, bei der wirklich nur die ganz ganz oben profitieren.
Und das sind nicht nur prominente Coaches, die das Wort Mindset holen.
Das ist ja bei allen Schneeballsystemen so, oder Pyramidensystemen, wie auch immer man
es nennt.
Manch einer nennt es auch Strukturvertrieb, weil das nicht so anstößig klingt.
Nicht nur die Künstler sagen als den Namen ihrer Kinder, sondern auch Arbeitgebern.
Denn Menschen davon zu überzeugen, dass nur sie die Schmiede ihres eigenen Glücks sind
und dass sie Kraft ihrer Mentalität über Wohl und Unwohl entscheiden können, nimmt
vor allem Last von den Schultern derjeniger, die am Hebel für die Ursachen echter profitieren.
Nee, das ist auf Twitch nicht so.
Gut, am Ende kannst du sagen, oben sitzt Bezos und der verdient fett.
Aber zumindest ist es ja auf Twitch nicht so, dass ich jetzt jemanden werbe, der sich
dort registriert.
Und wenn der streamt und Geld macht, krieg ich von ihm was ab.
Das ist ja Blödsinn.
Also das ist ja auf Twitch nicht so.
Offensichtlich.
Du hast keinen übergeordneten Twitch-Streamer oder so.
Schlechte Arbeitsbedingungen, toxische Unternehmenskulturen, geringe Löhne, sinnlose Arbeit oder unrealistische
Stellenanforderungen.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von teilweise nur methodisch fragwürdigen bis eindeutig tierqueren
Experten.
Hast du das mit Twitch Korea mitbekommen?
Nö.
... für Studien, der in der Psychologie stark kritisierten sogenannten
Positive Psychology, die genau das immer wieder zu belegen vorgibt, dass es eigentlich
nur aufs Mindset ankommt.
Na klar.
Wir wissen ja, man muss nix können, man muss einfach nur dran glauben.
Und die zentralen Figuren dieses Positive Psychology-Einschlags werden von internationalen
Großinvestoren, die regelmäßig an Arbeitnehmer feindlicher Organisationen spenden, mit Millionenbeträgen
subventioniert.
Weil die Überzeugung, als Arbeitnehmer nur von sich aus einen besseren Lebensstandard
erreichen zu können, tatsächlich hilfreich ist.
Es gibt natürlich...
Ja gut, man sollte jetzt aber nicht vergessen, dass selbstverständlich schon erstmal jeder
für sich selbst verantwortlich ist.
Sicherlich gibt es enorm viele Faktoren, wie gut deine Voraussetzungen sind.
Es heißt jetzt aber nicht, dass du mit ner guten Idee was im Hirn und der nötigen Arbeit
nicht tatsächlich was schaffen kannst.
Man darf aber auch nicht unerwähnt lassen.
Dass es in einem Großteil der Fälle trotz nicht blöder Leute und trotz viel Arbeitseinsatz
nicht klappt.
Das ist ja das, was bei diesen Mindset-Sachen prinzipiell immer ausgeblendet wird.
Sobald du das richtige Mindset hast, ist alles gut.
Auch gute Coaches, die für gewöhnlich aber anders arbeiten, als man es aus den Medien
wirksam ist.
Ich musste auch letztens erst nen Teambuilding-Workshop machen mit nem Coach.
Wobei, ich würde den nicht in Richtung Mindset-Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Coach einsortieren.
Das war enorm anstrengend wieder.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, was da auch irgendwie nicht rauskommt.
Du kannst zwar ne gute Idee haben und du kannst auch schlau sein und viel Arbeit reinschneiden,
was Gutes entwickeln.
Wenn es aber im Endeffekt halt keinen gibt, der es haben will, hast du auch gelitten.
Da bringt dir das geile Mindset auch nichts.
Ich kenne keine Statistik, wie viele Prozent der Startups es nicht schaffen.
Aber mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir mal, 80 Prozent der Startups packen es nicht über die ersten
drei Jahre so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Aber so über den Daumen gepeilt würde ich das einfach mal sagen.
Ja.
Das sind die ersten fünf Jahre.
80 Prozent der Startups packen nicht die ersten fünf Jahre.
Und denen mangelt es wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr an Ideen, Arbeitseinsatz und Mindset.
Sondern manche Sachen heben halt einfach nicht ab.
Unabhängig und zurückhaltend.
Und nicht zuletzt sollte von Anfang an klar sein, was das konkrete Ziel des Coachings
ist.
Kein simples, ich mach nicht reich.
Oder werden gekauft.
Naja gut, das ist ja das Ziel von vielen Startups sogar.
Gekauft werden, Asche machen und next.
Sondern so etwas wie erstellen eines Businessplans.
Und für dieses konkrete Ziel sollte dann eine feste Anzahl an Sitzungen, meist so um
die acht bis fünfzehn, festgelegt und eingehalten werden.
Kein, jetzt könnt ihr euch direkt.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Businessplan?
Da müsste man sich ja erst mal überlegen, was man eigentlich machen will und wie man
damit Geld verdienen will.
Wie?
Das passt ja zu Mindset schon mal gar nicht.
Das hat ja was mit Planung und Ideen.
Und da muss man ja wirklich was machen damit zu tun.
Nee, das ist ja kein Wunder, dass sich das nicht gut verkauft.
Es ist ja, guck mal, wenn du den Leuten erzählen kannst, ihr müsst wirklich was machen.
Ja, also ihr müsst dafür wirklich Ideen haben, das umsetzen, euch was überlegen,
euch reinhängen, auch mal vielleicht mit dem einen oder anderen Rückschlag klarkommen
oder es kommt ja alles zugeflogen, wenn du nur das richtige Mindset hast.
Ja, dann ist klar, wofür sich viele Leute entscheiden.
Für die easy Sache.
Für die easy Sache, ja, richtiges Mindset und es kommt ja alles zu mir, ja.
Klappt halt nicht.
Ein Sonderangebot für das nächste Seminar anmelden.
Und zuletzt, das bedeutet natürlich nicht, dass es sinnlos ist, sich mit sich selbst,
seiner Motivation oder der Einrichtung seines Arbeitsplatzes zu befassen.
Man sollte nur von den dadurch erlangten Erkenntnissen nicht die in Coachings oder YouTube-Videos
angepriesene Produktivitätskaskade erwarten.
Ja, es kann hilfreich sein, sein Handy in der Schublade statt auf dem Schreibtisch liegen
zu lassen, wenn man sich konzentrieren will.
Das ist aber nicht der Stein, der bisher den Pfad zum Multimilliardär blockiert hat.
Sich regelmäßig zu vergegenwärtigen, was man im Leben noch so erreichen will, kann
auch helfen, aber bei weitem nicht so viel, wie die unvorteilhaften Umstände einen daran
hindern werden.
Das heißt, leider taugt Mindset nicht nur so gut wie gar nichts, es hindert uns in manchen
Fällen sogar daran, echte Veränderungen in Gang zu setzen.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Wer heute noch unironisch von Mindset spricht, der hat sich dem offensichtlich selbst noch
nicht vergegenwärtigt.
Und das ist furchtbar schade.
Ich habe es gerade den letzten Monat voll abgeschaut, bis es wieder runter geht.
Ein ganzer Stonk geht richtig steil.
Der Absturz von Halo.
Da habe ich letztens ein Alpha4-Games-Video zugesehen.
Ihr verkackt Infinite immer neues.
Ich fand es echt cool, wenn man den Anfang vom Halo-Prozess auf einmal ein seines junto
genommen hat.
Soll nicht andere solche Dinge sein, die überhaupt nichts davon haben.
Aber ich will zwar ein paar Ideen dazu zeigen.
Aber ich will wohl einen.
Ich fand es am Anfang ja echt gut.
Leider kam noch nichts mehr.
Leute, ich habe übertrieben
Hunger. Und ich
muss jetzt die Belege für meine
Steuererklärung raussuchen.
Dazu brauche ich ernsthaft das richtige Mindset.
Es geht nur, wenn ich ordentlich
was gefressen habe vorher, sonst halte ich das nicht aus.
Was gibt es heute zu futtern? Es gibt...
Pass auf, wer weiß es?
Ich glaube, ich habe es sogar schon am Anfang gesagt.
Es gibt nicht Lachs
mit Nudel.
Das heißt, was ist die zweite andere Sache,
die es gibt bei mir Samstag, wenn es nicht Lachs gibt?
Nudel mit Bolognese.
Richtig. Korrekt.
Hat der ein neues Video über was?
Die gucke ich gerne. Aber nicht unbedingt
zwei Stunden hier on stream.
History of Punchout.
Okay.
Pog.
Kann ich mir jetzt beim Essen angucken.
Vorhin sagtest du nur Tomatensauce.
Ja, das war halt das Einfachste jetzt zu sagen.
Tomatensauce. Nein, das ist nicht nur Tomatensauce.
Das ist Tomatensauce mit Hackfleisch
drin und dann gibt es wieder jede Menge
Käse oben drüber, sodass das
Ganze im Endeffekt mehr nach Käse anstatt
nach Tomatensauce schmeckt.
Heute ist Sonntag. Ja, wie komme ich auf Samstag?
Hast du einen Thermomix?
Ne.
Habe ich nicht.
Braucht man das für das richtige Mindset?
Gut, Leute.
Dann arbeitet mal an eurem Mindset.
Bis zum nächsten Stream.
Ich gehe mir jetzt was zu essen machen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.
Ciao.